哈喽 大家好。
我们又来讲废话喽。
我们今天要来讲一本被我的朋友称之为。
原生家庭教科书。
性质的这样的一本书。
对，而且我看完这本书的感觉，
因为我一开始我会觉得好像这本书可能跟我关系不大。
然后我看了以后我看到结束，就是和上此书的时候我会有一种，
我不相信有人看了这本书会说我完全没有一个对照了。
我觉得不可能。
我觉得不管是东亚家长还是欧美家长，
我觉得全世界家长或多或少我觉得都会有一些。
有可能他的症状不是非常的明显，
或者是说他不成熟到如此地步，
但是我觉得或多或少，
大家都会感觉到这就是我的爸妈，
就是会说这句话。
本期节目也要感谢小雨傘的特别赞助，
跟传统保险公司不同，
是一家全国性的保险经济公司，
连接八十多家保险公司优势产品，
帮选帮赔。
对保险有需求的朋友，
可以在节目简介，
就是shownotes里面找到相应的链接，
预约咨询我们的保险顾问小雨傘，
匹配保险方案，
消除信息不对称，
咨询时还可以领取一万元女性妨碍保障，
能包乳线癌，
供给癌等七种高发特定癌症，
确诊级配，
以及一份三万元的承认意外保障，
直接找顾问就可以领。
好，那让我们先进入本期的话题，
首先先跟大家讲这本书叫什么吧，
这本书的说明叫做不成熟的父母，
作者他是一位经验丰富的心理治疗师，
而且他也是一个心理学研究和理论的学者，
所以在这本书里面他既有理论，
也在每一个理论后面都会跟着一些他咨询时候遇到的一些案例，
来解释这个问题，
所以我们就算看理论的时候你会觉得，
询换看不懂，
但是你看那个事情本身你就熟悉，
经历过，
你就知道了这个事情是这本书是给你写的，
我看这本书是因为我首页我有个朋友，
他在看这本书，
然后他就发了一条微博说他还没有把这个书看完，
但是他相信所有人都会需要看这本书，
然后就想真的吗，
因为我特别不喜欢看这种，
什么原生家庭啊，
创伤啊，
如何处理跟母的关系啊什么的，
我心中，
我觉得我还是有一点回避这件事情的，
我就觉得我在现实生活中受的罪还不够多吗，
你要让我去看这种书，
让我去review这种痛苦，
让我去仔细分析品味，
然后还要去理论里面对照啊，
那我收不了这个，
但是我看我朋友就是如此的大家赞赏之后，
我就产生了深深的好奇，
我就想说我肯定是要看一下，
然后宴就说我们来做这个吧，
我就想OK，那正好就看一下，
我是看之前啊，
我就在想说，
不成熟的父母，
我们已经做完了，
我们做了那个妈妈，
我不是你的老公，
那其实我就是感觉我们已经做过这种题目了，
然后我稍微看了一下这本书，
我还没有看完的时候，
我就想说好，
我们只做了其中很小的一个部分，
就是我们说的，
想要让自己的小孩成为自己的老公也好啊，
或者是成为自己的，
Maybe是老婆吧，
Maybe是自己的家长，
Maybe是自己的领导，
或者是自己的引路人那种，
其实是不成熟父母里面，
非常非常小的一部分，
或者是说一个小小的分支吧，
说到不成熟的父母，
你就会像我们一样，
会想说这期跟我没有关系，
然后但是，
我们只要把书里面，
因为书里面一开始，
就是跟我们分享了说好，
我如何判断我的父母是不成熟的父母呢，
他就会给我们一些例子，
你的父母有没有如下特质呢，
你有没有跟你的父母的相处过程中，
有如下的感受呢，
那我们就跟大家也一起分享上，
就是现在在听的朋友你也可以看一下，
你和你父母平常相处的时候，
有没有这些特点，
这就是我们判断，
你的父母是不是不成熟的父母，
第一个是和他们交流才很困难，
或者是根本无法交流，
你感觉永远都是，
自己单方面试图和父母沟通，
而他对你说的话题不感兴趣，
我看到这句话我已经想说好，
我已经中了，
因为我妈确实不太喜欢跟我聊一些，
比方说我们很关心的实证问题，
类似要不要全民敬严这样子，
或者是说之前的油管车混装，
我会觉得这不是我一个人问题，
这个就是全社会，
大家都应该共同关注的问题，
然后我每次一试图，
跟我的父母聊到这种问题，
他们就会有一种关你什么事的这种感受，
我觉得还有一种，
就他们认为这个问题你管得了吗，
就算你认为你不满意，
那你有什么能力要改变呢，
你既然没有能力来改变的话，
你关心他有什么意义呢，
我觉得很多话题是这个方面，
不仅仅是他不关心与你感兴趣的东西，
因为有的朋友是跟爸妈分享说，
我今天比较说在学校参加了一个歌唱比赛，
爸妈可能会觉得歌唱比赛，
不会影响你的学习吧，
这个方面是对于你个人的兴趣不感兴趣，
对于你的个人的爱好不感兴趣，
那我说的这种是，
对于整个关于你想要聊的那些生活中我认为较大的事情，
他也没有兴趣，
这个就是非常重要的点，
我就看了这个我想说好，
然后下一句叫做，
他们只希望别人关注他们自己感兴趣的东西，
并且千方百计地吸引他人的注意，
其实这一点我就是有点犹豫，
因为我其实到现在，
我根本不知道他们感兴趣的东西是什么，
我就又陷入一种好，
是不是我对爸妈的关心也不够，
第二个呢，就是他们很少直接谈论自己的感受，
然后说他不会跟你说，
宝贝我会觉得我们最近好像有点疏远了，
或者是说我们很久没有跟你谈心了，
他们会用情绪来表达，
例如大家都懂得饭桌上没有人说话，
大家在爸爸或妈妈反正就是在家长拉长了脸的气氛中吃完了一顿饭，
这就是用情绪来表达自己的需求，
第三种叫做他们很难被取悦，
或者是很难接近，
我觉得这个还，
只要是东亚的小孩都会有这种感受吧，
就是你家里如果没有一个这样威严的爸爸，
威严答应好，
那就会有一个威严的爷爷，
就是你不知道要怎么样跟他开启对话，
甚至你如果用一些，
我们如果换算到外语的话，
就是你不用敬于跟他说话，
他就会生气的那种障碍，
就是例如你可能会跟他开个玩笑啊，
或者是说外公你带红帽子很可爱这些，
他就马上生气了，
他就认为你不尊重我，
你怎么这样跟我讲话，
我就觉得会有这样的一个东西，
因为他们会比较强调于角色，
就是会不停地跟你重复，
我是你爹，
或者我是你妈，
就是会时时刻刻提醒你，
他在这个家里的角色，
比方说他们还会经常说，
因为我是你爹，
所以我可以，
因为我是你妈，
因为你是小孩，
所以你要听话，
小孩,
所以你要服从我们的需求，
就是他们会用家庭的角色，
来代替他们真正的情感也好，
或者跟你交流的欲望也好，
然后最后一点，
就是他们希望和你产生，
纠缠的年纪，
而不是真正的亲密感，
我觉得说这个，
大家可能不太容易理解，
但是你随便举个例子，
你就很容易能够感觉到，
比方说你跟你爸妈说，
我觉得我已经长大了，
我认为我已经可以，
比方说我自己搬出去住，
或者说我认为我可以交往对象，
不管是男还是女，
还是同性还是异性，
然后我认为我可以自己决定，
我要花这笔钱去看个演唱会，
然后他们就会，
第一个，习惯性的先阻止你，
然后会产生一些，
哦，是啦，你现在吃饱饮了，
你一定不需要爸爸妈妈了，
就是会跟你讲这些话，
他们希望就用这个东西来，
黏住你，
而不是真正的跟你保持，
情绪上的亲密，
因为情绪上的亲密，
大家可以理解，
就是那种，
你愿意跟你爸妈分享，
你追的心是什么啊，
你为什么会喜欢这个明星啊，
或者是你喜欢一些什么摇滚月啊，
或者你喜欢某些画展啊，
他们可以真正的就着这个东西，
来跟你讨论，
哦，不要关心你，
为什么会喜欢啊，
或者你喜欢它哪里啊，
或者是说，
哎，那你之前喜欢那个，
那你为什么又不喜欢了呢，
发生了什么呢，
这个才是正常的，
亲自关心里面的亲密，
而不是我们前面说的那种，
你爸妈发现你一旦要，
哼，要离开我的控制了，
要吃饱饮了，
飞出去了，
要再也不是我的管辖了，
就会产生一些恐慌，
或者试图再控制你这些东西，
好，这句说我们刚刚说的，
不知道，
在听的朋友们，
有没有已经有一种，
如茫刺背，如做真正，
这种感受，
关于燕讲的那几点，
其实在这本书里面，
被作者总扩为，
这些父母是情感不成熟的父母，
而且我特别喜欢他最一开始讲的这个话，
他提出这些问题之后，
他就在跟我们对话，
他说,
客观看待你的父母，
可能是一件很难的事情，
因为这种感觉，
就像你背叛了他们，
但这不是本书的目的所在，
他说,
我们最终的目的是，
让你们能够客观的看待自己父母，
而不是不尊重他们，
或者背叛他们，
而且这个作者，
真的让我觉得非常有意思，
他讲了一个点，
叫做,
你在本书中学到的东西，
你没有分享的义务，
我当时看的时候，
哈哈大笑，
因为他真的是在跟你对话，
而不是说，
我就告诉你这些，
然后你看完了之后，
你准备要干嘛，
我就不管了，
这不管我的事，
他完全就是预测到了，
有些朋友可能会看完这些书之后，
就会觉得说，
哦，原来如此，
我找到病因了，
现在我要去治病救人，
然后他就说，
没有救治的义务，
之类的，
当然他不是说你完全，
不应该去解决所有的问题，
但是他明确的提出了一点，
就是,
这件事情，
他首先要达到的东西，
是叫做，
你要理解你是怎么长大的，
你要理解你的处境，
什么你的家庭关系，
塑造了你这个人，
这些情感上不成熟的父母，
给你带来了什么样的影响，
你对于自身的这个觉察，
是这个书里面的核心任务，
而不是说你拿着这本书，
要把你的父母变成一个，
你可能本来你就做不到这件事情，
他没有提出一些不切实际的目标，
而且我原来会认为，
产生这样的心理的人，
就不是很多，
因为,
可能是我觉得我们的那个，
听众里面，
大家已经能够，
比较冷静的面对，
我们的亲子关系了，
已经可以接受，
我的爸妈不是完美的爸妈，
这件事情了，
那然后我们才能，
继续下面的讨论嘛，
然后刚巧我不是，
这段时间在做那个康复训练吗，
然后那天就跟我的那个，
康复师聊天，
后来我就发现，
他是一个很逃避对话的人，
然后我也是无意中说的，
因为他就是问我，
他说你觉得我是个什么样的人，
我说我发现你是一个很逃避对话，
我就是试图，
跟他,
稍微聊一点深刻的东西，
但是我也不知道，
怎么要跟我的康复师聊深刻的东西，
可能是他，
表现出这样的需求吧，
我就说，
我觉得你是很逃避的人，
他就说，
为什么，
然后我们就稍微聊了一下，
后来他就很困惑，
他就说，
那我为什么会变成这样一个人呢，
然后我就说，
我说我认为，
可能跟你原生家庭关系较大，
可能你爸妈也是这么对待你的，
然后你就习惯了跟别人讲话，
别人比方说，
稍微想要跟你聊一些深的，
你就马上打哈哈呀，
或者开玩笑啊，
或者是说一些牛逼牛逼，
牛逼这种话想要混过去啊，
就是这种东西，
然后他马上就不高兴了，
你知道吗，
他就说，
我爸妈挺好的啊，
他的例子没有了，
那时候就马上站出来维护他，
我说,
你爸妈很好，
你爸妈很爱你，
和他是一个逃避的人，
这些事情是完全不矛盾的，
你能理解吗，
然后他就陷入了城市，
我说,
我跟你讲这些话，
就是说，
我认为你的原生家庭，
可能对你产生的这些影响，
我不是在骂你爸妈，
也不是在说你爸妈，
比方说，
养孩子都养不好，
完全没有指责的意思，
也完全没有说，
我就要你去什么，
逃除家庭，
反叛家庭，
我感觉他立刻，
就竖起了这样的刺，
他的敌意就是非常的重，
然后我就说，
其实你爸妈，
可能不是非常完美的爸妈，
或者是非常合格的爸妈，
但是他可能很爱你，
他对你很好，
他比方说，
辛辛苦苦养育了你，
这些都是从事存在的，
你依然可以做一个大孝子，
完全是OK的，
但是你也要认清，
你的原生家庭，
可能跟你带来这些影响，
因为你想要改变吗？
你想要变成一个
不是逃避的人吗？
那你首先要找到你的病，
跟在哪里，
我们才能一致吗？
我就跟他聊完以后，
我再突然意识到，
原来有这么多人，
心里其实还是很抵触，
要去说，
爸妈妈不好这件事，
而且我们就已经说惯了，
爸妈坏话的人，
就已经，
有这个心理障碍了，
其实话又说回来，
虽然我们自己说，
我们是说惯了，
爸妈坏话的人，
但其实我在讲，
讲一些，
所谓的讲坏话的时候，
我内心深处，
还是会有一种，
我是否背叛了，
他们对我的好，
因为父母从小到大，
把你养到大，
他不可能，
完全对你，
一点关心和爱都没有，
这是不可能的吗？
然后我就会觉得说，
那如果我讲，
他们对我不好的事情，
是不是就背叛了，
他们对我好的那一方面，
就好像，
把他们，
讲成了一个，
完全的坏人一样的，
这对他们，
是否是不公平的，
但是另一方面，
我又想，
那谁管对我，
不公平呢？
并没有人在乎啊！
对，而且我是觉得，
因为原生家庭，
亲子关系，
他本来就是个很复杂的关系，
他不可能只有一个伪毒，
就不可能说，
你爸妈，
只虐待你，
或者是，
只单纯的对你好，
这都不可能存在，对吧？
而且我想说，
你跟你爸妈，
相处了这么多年，
你们没有过，
互相怨恨的时刻吗？
没有过，
吵架的时刻吗？
没有过觉得，
他不理解你的时刻吗？
他没有觉得，
他本身就是一个
很复杂的东西，
我觉得看这本书，
以及我们大家的
互相探讨，
是让更多人，
能够理解，
为什么，
比方说，
我跟我爸妈代替，
就是那么的不开心呢？
到底是我做错了，
还是他做错了，
还是我们都有错呢？
还是我们，
就是根本没有认清楚，
我们之间，
到底出了什么问题呢？
我觉得这些书，
其实给大家一个参考，
也就是，
刚刚那个他说的，
他不是要求你说，
好，我们看了这本书，
好，回家就把家砸了！
不是这样的一个东西！
没错!
好，我们建立这样，
一个大前提之后，
我们再来看作者，
除了燕刚讲的那几点后，
我再做一个补充，
因为他有详细的描述说，
不成熟的父母，
就情感不成熟的父母，
其实他们在根子上来说，
是叫做，
一种情感不成熟的人吗？
那他们为什么，
会形成这样的一种，
情感不成熟的模式，
导致他们没有办法，
很好的处理，
家庭关系也好，
亲密关系也好，
即便成了大人，
还是这样子，
那这是另外一个话题，
首先我们要做的是识别他们，
然后他提出了一些，
行为上的标准，
我看的时候，
经常会会心一笑，
就比如说，
这作者他就说，
他们非常以自我为重心，
因为所有情感不成熟的人，
都非常以自我为重心，
他们很在意自己的需求，
是否得到满足，
或者某个东西，
是否得罪了他们，
他们的自尊，
取决于其他人，
如何对待自己，
他们无法接受，
被人批评，
所以他们会忽视，
自己犯的错，
因为他们自我，
意识过于强烈，
总觉得自己的需求，
比别人的感受更重要，
例如一个女人，
告诉她的母亲，
听到她母亲的批评，
让她很伤心，
她的母亲却会说，
如果不跟你说，
我就没有任何人可以说，
好，我看到这里，
我就笑出声了，
因为这个话，
一模一样的话，
我在我妈那里听到过，
然后我就，
被我自主地说，
OK，好的，我知道了，
然后下一个他说，
他们习惯自我参照，
而非自我反省，
他的具体表现是什么呢，
就是无论你说什么，
他都要把话题，
转到他那里去，
就不关心你时间上说什么，
就算他有一些人，
他可能稍微懂一些社交礼貌，
他会等你讲一段时间，
但是,
他不会对你的话题，
真的感兴趣，
他不会接你的话差，
也不会对你的经历，
表示好奇，
他就会随随地，
把这个话给敷衍过去，
然后最终，
又扯到他们自己身上，
所以你跟他的交流，
其实是没有办法，
形成一个双向的交流的，
他跟你交谈的目的，
只有一个，
就是他要讲他的，
而不是，
你听他讲，
他听你讲，
你们两个交流，
然后他说，
因为不懂自我反省，
所以,
情感不成熟的人，
在出现问题的时候，
从不考虑自己应该怎么做，
他们不会去评价自己的行为，
或是对自己的动机提出疑问，
如果热了麻烦，
他们会说，
自己本无意伤害你，
然后就把事忘了，
毕竟,
不知者无罪吗，
最终,
他们在意的人仍然是自己，
而不是对你是否造成了影响，
好,
这一段话，
听起来非常的绕，
其实这个事非常的简单，
就是叫做，
你伤心了怎么了，
我又不是故意的，
我给你道个歉，
爸爸妈妈给你道个歉，
我们过去了好玩，
我们现在这样，
你虎这个脸，
有什么意思呢，
大家坐在这里，
还要不要吃饭了，
大家一家人，
心情都搞得这么不好，
有这个必要吗，
我们都说对不起了，
你还要不高兴到什么时候，
你看最终，
他不是在乎说，
你因为这件事情，
受到了伤害，
然后要把这件事情，
可以聊清楚，
他不会真的去反省，
他做了什么，
或者他说了什么，
对你造成了什么样的影响，
而是说，
赶紧接过去算了，
所以他这个特点叫做，
他不会真正的反省，
然后还有一个，
很有意思的点，
我之前从来没有想到过，
这个点叫做，
进行概念性思考，
会遇到很多障碍，
什么叫概念性思考，
就是,
相对来说，
不是我们今天要吃什么，
喝什么的问题，
而是我们开始，
要在一个问题上面，
讲逻辑了，
就是这个事儿，
怎么发生呢，
他背后有什么样的原因，
可能有什么样的方式，
有解决这个事情的办法，
以及我们抽象出来，
这个事情背后，
可能会有ABC第四个观点，
这四个观点里面，
可能大家都有一定的道理，
然后我们就，
来对这个问题，
进行一个，
较为深度的，
较为复杂的讨论，
这也是刚刚艳说的，
当我们讨论，
一些社会议题的时候，
经常要做的事情，
因为他，
既然成为了一个社会话题，
就说明他，
肯定不是，
那么直白，
那么简单的一个东西嘛，
不成熟的人，
他因为他们常常很焦虑，
情绪很激烈，
所以他们没有办法，
达到那样的一种，
思维的状态，
因为他们，
基本上都是被情绪，
占领了大脑，
所以他们很难，
在被受压力的情况下，
理性思考，
当谈到，
容易激发情绪的话题，
他们的头脑，
马上就会陷入，
僵化的，
非黑即白的思想中，
拒绝任何复杂的，
思想碰撞，
当然有一些，
情感不成熟的人，
只有,
当他们在，
太多威胁的时候，
能够进行，
概念性的思考，
而且他们这时候，
非常有迷惑性的，
一点来了，
他们这时候，
甚至还表现得，
很有动筝力，
就是很讲逻辑，
很讲道理，
然后你说什么，
他们也会，
确实大家都能达成一致，
他说,
但这种情况，
仅限于谈论的话题，
没有激起，
他们的情绪的时候，
才会发生，
这让他们的孩子，
非常困惑，
因为孩子看到了，
父母,
完全不同的两个方面，
实而非常具有智慧，
非常理性，
实而非常狭隘，
难以相处，
然后我看到这个时候，
天呐,
我又露出了笑容，
我就想，
原来是这样，
我就立刻想到了，
我跟我爸，我妈，
讨论一些政治问题，
还要讨论一些新闻，
就是社会公共话题的时候，
他们经常会，
爆发出这种，
让我不是很理解的，
有时候，
是能说得上，
能说得通的，
而且他们会跟我，
讨论一些社会话题，
然后也能达出一个，
关心社会的人，
都能达出的，
一致性的结论，
然后有些时候，
比如说，
当你谈到了，
生育率的问题，
这也是一个，
社会话题对吧，
但是立刻就激发了，
我爸妈的，
好，我们没有孙子啦，
我们没有孙女啦，
的PTSD,
然后他们立刻投脑，
你就能看到，
他们投脑，
马上被这个情绪，
给占领了之后，
立刻就开始批判，
年轻人的生活方式，
思想,
被什么什么，
图独啦，
怎么怎么的，
生小孩，
你们全都这样，
什么自私，
你看,
这一套东西，
你能很明显感觉，
是怎么回事儿啦，
然后这时候，
我就非常能够感觉到，
没有办法沟通，
也没有办法讨论，
这就是，
俗称就是上头啦，
对,
因为他们很容易把，
探讨一个问题，
马上转化到，
你在攻击我，
你借助这个问题，
其实你是想挑战我，
你是在骂我，
因为你知道，
我们大家在讨论问题的时候，
就是我就觉得，
正常的朋友，
例如你跟你的朋友在一起，
你跟你的同事在一起，
大家讨论一个问题，
即使我们有不同的观点，
但是大家也能够理解，
我们只是针对这个问题，
发生了分歧，对吧，
跟你这个人没有关系，
但是你跟爸妈聊这个问题，
他很容易产生，
你什么意思，
你是不是对我不满，
所以你要在这个问题上，
反驳我，
你反驳我，
是不是你瞧不起我了，
你觉得我们老了，
跟不上了，
所以就是，
跟你聊不到一块儿了，
就是很容易把这个问题上升，
我觉得这个也是一个很明显的，
这林塞博士说的，
他的情绪，
一旦占领了他的头脑以后，
他就再也没有办法，
就事论事，
或者是以逻辑来跟你讨论，
他很容易，
又会回到那个问题，
我是你爹，
我是你妈，
你就这样跟我说话，
你就会，
本来小孩，
就是在跟你正常的讨论嘛，
当然也认为，
我们在进行一些很，
普通的对话，
突然就变成了一种，
你要跪下来大哭，
就是要给我爸妈洗脚，
要进入了这样的情绪，
所以小孩肯定会，
摸不着头脑，
还有一个表现，
刚刚叶也稍微提到一句，
就是叫做，
他们通过情绪传染，
与人进行沟通，
我当时看到这个时候，
我就想，
原来,
这有个名词，
描述这种情况呀，
他这个作者是怎么说的呢，
他说,
因为情绪不成熟的人，
对自己的感受，
一直不强，
缺乏情感体验，
所以他们通常会，
表现自己的需求，
而不是谈论他们的情感需求，
所以他们就会使用，
这种叫做，
情绪传染的沟通方式，
来让别人，
体会他们的感受，
这个话，
听起来很绕，
其实非常简单，
叫做,
你不懂茶颜观色吗？
你没有看出来，
我心情不好吗？
哦,
家里都这样了，
你还在那儿大吃大喝，
嘻嘻哈哈，
你难道看不出来，
我们很不高兴吗？
这就是一种，
情绪传染的方式，
他说,
情绪传染，
其实有个非常典型的表现，
是婴儿，
因为婴儿，
他没有办法讲话嘛，
所以他只能通过，
哭啊，闹啊，
然后让照顾者，
意识到，
婴儿很不舒服，
来解决，
这种情绪，
从不舒服的婴儿身上，
传染到了，
承认的身上，
才会,
迫使照顾者，
想尽一切办法，
来安抚孩子，
那这个东西，
其实落到了，
我们的家庭里面，
如果,
父母情感不成熟的话，
他就会，
采取这样的一种方式，
他们苦闹的时候，
他们会让自己的孩子，
和周围的，
每一个人，
都感到很沮丧，
这样做的结果，
通常就是，
别人愿意，
请来让他们舒服些，
这个,
延伸的一个东西，
叫做,
他们不做情感工作，
什么叫情感工作，
就是你要去理解别人，
你要去，
感受别人的感受，
你要为别人着想，
或者是，
希望大家都开心，
然后做一些，
让大家都开心的事情，
比方说，
约着爸妈说，
我们今天一起去看个电影吧，
我们今天一起，
进行一些，
比方说家庭晚餐，
就是你得，
做出一些，
让所有人，
都开心的工作，
对,
朋友们，
这里要注意的是，
一般在一个，
情感成熟的父母，
在家庭里面，
一个较为健康的，
家庭关系里面，
这件事情，
是应该父母做的，
因为小孩，
更不成熟啊，
小孩的情感，
机智,
还有他的大脑发育，
他整体都是一个弱者，
你让他，
反而来承担这一些的话，
就是,
其实是道志了嘛，
这个是我们之前，
其实,
大家可能，
在网上，
就已经看到过这个词，
亲直化，
亲是亲人的亲，
直是直业的直，
亲直化是什么意思呢，
就是儿童，
或亲少年，
在家庭中，
承担起，
本应由父母承担的，
照顾者的角色，
你是作为父母双亲，
这是你的职责，
结果,
这个职责，
放到了小孩身上，
所以他们小孩，
去做这件事情的时候，
就让小孩的行为，
形成了一种，
叫做亲直化的，
这样的一个现象，
这种行为倾向，
就像我们刚刚说的，
在正常的家庭里面，
比较健康的家庭里面，
应该是大人，
因为大人是更强势的，
去照顾小孩的感受，
或者去问小孩，
更弱势的一个孩子，
一个更厉害的大人，
我来帮你解决问题，
或者我们一起，
来面对我们家庭里面，
或者怎么样，
而不说反过来，
我要求你来体察，
我有什么样的需求，
这就是倒过来了，
就让小孩走入，
亲直化的一个情况，
然后我看这里的时候，
我就有一种，
我不知道艳有没有，
你有没有这样的感觉，
因为这就是我，
从小到大的感觉，
而且这不是一个，
默认的事情，
是我爸妈，
在嘴巴上面，
提出来的要求，
就是,
首先,
情绪传染这件事情，
是从我有记忆以来，
我爸就是
我们家的最大的
情绪传染员，
我在之前的节目里面，
也提到过，
我爸就是那种，
他一回家，
他低气，
就让所有人都
不能高兴的那种男的，
他坐在饭桌上，
要是不说话，
大家说话，
嘻嘻哈哈，
或者很欢乐，
什么，都被视作，
是向他的挑战，
就你不尊重他的情绪，
你就不会看脸色吗？
你没有看出来，
他很不高兴吗？
就很明显，
我的家庭里面，
是一直处于这样的一个，
前台词的，
就我很小，
我就已经知道，
我爸的情绪，
在我们家的，
环境里面的，
优先级是最高的，
所有人都要看他脸色，
我妈的情绪，
虽然也很重要，
但肯定没有我爸重要，
在这种情况下，
会发生一个情绪传染，
第二个东西呢，
就是我们刚刚说的那个，
叫做,
小孩,
要去照顾大人的感受，
面对情绪传染的时候，
小孩要做情绪工作，
我爸妈在吵架了之后，
首先,
他们吵架，
会让我来评历，
当我还是，
非常非常小的儿童的时候，
我都不说现在了，
我都，我都这么大人了，
我成年都非常多年了，
当我还是，
都不说是上中学吧，
我上小学的时候，
我就要，
评判,
和调挺我爸妈之间的，
纷争,
以及当他们大吵架，
我完全是不知所措的，
我完全不知道，
应该怎么办的时候，
我非常确定的时候，
我就是小学生，
而且小学第年级，
然后他们两个，
大吵大闹之后，
好像我忘了那次，
是闹离婚，
还是怎么样吧，
我的家里面，
坐满了，
我们家的亲戚，
因为我们家，
也是一个很大的家族，
大家互相之间，
就会干涉对方的家事，
的那种，
我们整个家庭，
就是一个，
纠葛的关系，
然后,
在这种情况下，
我的亲戚们，
就来说我，
你爸妈吵架，
为什么你不管？
好害羞哦，
对,
我就觉得说，
我怎么管，
我是这个家里，
最没有权力的人，
我怎么管他们，
他们每个人，
都可以管我，
难道能去打他们吗？
我是一个小孩的时候，
我听到这个话，
我就非常的困惑，
而且所有人，
都对我讲这个话，
是非常立直气壮的，
是在指责我，
而且我爸妈，
他们也不说，
听了这个话之后，
才会这样，
他们,
日常生活中，
当我在他们两个，
吵架的时候，
我不发义语，
然后他们两个，
非常不高兴的时候，
最终的落脚点，
都会落到，
迅持我，
上面来，
叫做,
现在爸爸妈，
弄得这么不高兴了，
你就什么都不做，
你在旁边看，
不能说点好笑的事情，
说点有意思的事情，
来让我们高兴高兴，
这个家里，
你没有责任吗？
这就是我从小到大，
听到的话，
就我对我父母的情绪，
和他们的舒适，
和他们的情感，
关系出现问题了之后，
我是负有责任的，
而且这件事情，
在我们的家里，
是一个绝对真理，
就没有任何讨论的空间，
不止他们怎么认为，
我们家亲戚怎么认为，
而且他们会指出一个，
例子叫做，
比如,
某某某家的某某哥哥，
他不是就很厉害吗？
他们爸爸妈妈吵架了，
他就是会站起来说，
拉着爸爸妈妈的手说，
你们两个不要再吵架了，
为了我，和好吧，
我不想让你们离婚，
然后所有人就举出，
这样的一个例子，
来教训我说，
你看，那个哥哥能做到，
为什么你做不到，
你一点眼力见都没有，
这就是我接受的教育，
所以我从小，
就被认为是一个，
不机灵的小孩，
因为我不会调停，
我父母的关系，
我就想到，
我朋友家的小孩，
就是一个这样的小孩，
他是,
因为跟他老公吵架的很凶，
但是那个小孩说的话，
也非常可怕，
他就会爆灶，
他们两个人，
吵完架以后不讲话，
然后那个小孩，
而且他们是在公共场所，
吵完架以后，
是类似医院这样子，
然后他们两个人，
就各走各的，
没有一个人想到，
小孩怎么办，
那时候小孩，
大概在四岁到五岁吧，
然后小孩就很着急，
小孩先铺上去，
抱住他爸爸的脚，
说不要生气，
爸爸不要走，
然后再回来抱住妈妈，
等到他爸爸真的停下脚步以后，
他再跑回来抱住妈妈，
然后他抱住妈妈的话，
说得非常奇怪，
是我朋友跟我讲的，
然后我想说，
小孩怎么会说这种话，
小孩说的是，
妈妈，你不要跟爸爸离婚，
因为你离开了爸爸，
你找不到别的男的，
然后,
对,
这种话，
对啊,
因为肯定就是爸爸教的嘛，
或者是平常爸妈的，
吵架中听到的这种话，
一般是四五岁小孩怎么会，
就是他怎么会自然产生这种话，
然后,
但是我朋友跟我讲的这个话，
是讲他小孩很贴心，
你看爸爸妈妈是需要小孩，
这样子，
我说,
小孩讲这种话，
因为我朋友认为，
就是小孩在开玩笑，
他不会是真心觉得，
小孩这么认为，
而且他会有一种，
天啊,
小孩真的苦苦的，
维系的那个家庭，
我听上去，
我只有一种小孩，
你也太可怜了吧，
因为那个小孩，
看上去就是一个，
非常懂得看脸色的那种小孩，
我第一次见到他，
然后他就会主动说，
我要叫姐姐，
还叫阿姨，
讲这种维心话的那种小孩，
天啊,
但我就会觉得，
这种小孩就是生活得很辛苦，
因为在我们家，
我认为，
我稍微好一点的是，
我妈这个字，
会有一点像你爸这样，
希望自己的情绪，
被全家看到，
并且全家来哄他，
但通常那是我爸的工作，
我爸会完成这件事情，
并且,
我爸会像小孩一样的，
就比较说，
开一个玩笑啊，
讲个冷笑话啊，
或者就是做一些
很滑稽的动作啊，
你知道男的嘛，
就是会有些
耍包的那种动作啊，
然后让我妈，
像炎青小说的那种女主角，
铺齿一笑，
这个事情，
就化为乌有。
所以,
在我爸去世之前，
我认为，
就是我爸帮我做了。
很多这样的工作，
所以我觉得，
我就是，
作为小孩就还好，
而且我爸妈会有一种，
比较正常的理念，
叫做,
吵架最好，
不要当的小孩面吵，
但是,
如果吵得很凶，
也是可以当的小孩面吵，
并且,
会,
经常会问说，
爸妈离婚你要跟谁？
嗯,
就是问小孩，
但是,
在我爸，
通常会帮我把大部分，
就是前面，
你需要做的工作，
已经在这个家庭里面，
做掉了。
所以,
我认为，
你有可能，
你们家，
爸妈两个人，
都是不成熟的，
也有可能，
你们家只有一个人，
是不成熟的，
那么,
他的伴侣，
可能就要成熟，
较大的压力，
同时,
小孩要协助部分，
我就这么说，
好就好，
但他适用于，
所有的家庭，
因为,
每个人家的情况，
都肯定是很不一样的，
因为,
这个我也是亲眼看到过，
虽然不是我们家的，
叫做,
情感不成熟的人，
他只喜欢做自己，
觉得舒服的事情，
他这里面就讲了一个例子，
他就讲他，
他有一个，
来访者，
因为他哥哥，
一起去，
跟他爸爸聊天，
讲谈一下，
那种养老院的事情，
然后呢，
稍微跟爸爸聊一会儿，
这个来访者，
就是个女生安娜，
他就觉得好，
那我们稍微寒暄的几句，
我们要开始，
进入正题，
要真的跟爸爸讲，
就是关于养老，
进养老院，
他哥哥不见了，
然后他想说，
怎么会这样，
他早变了屋子，
在窗前，
看到他哥开车走了，
哇塞,
我看到这个以后，
我就哈哈大笑，
因为我叔叔，
就是一个这样的人，
他有一次，
就是跟我审生，
其实共同也是，
跟我爷爷讨论，
就是那时候，
我奶奶去世了，
我爷爷，
就是要决定，
三个儿子，
到底要跟谁，
住在一起，
就这种问题，
那肯定是要聊一下嘛，
就比方说，
大家有什么态度啊，
什么的，
你怎么样啊，
气色不错啊，
没有营养的话，
他聊了很多，
并且,
确实通过他的努力，
让当时的气氛很轻松，
当要进入正式的话题，
那我们到底这些事情。
要怎么样，
到底跟谁住，
或者是一家住多几个月，
那住的人是不是要付钱，
就是进入非常正式。
承认对话的时候，
我叔叔就走了，
我叔叔，
但好就好，
在他没有真的开车走，
他就是在外面抽烟，
根本不加入这个对话，
就是由我审生，
他的老婆，
作为他们家的代表，
来进行这样的对话，
然后我想说，
哇，真的是好眼熟啊，
原来这件事情，
大家都在经历这段事情，
我还看到一个例子，
我印象也特别深，
就作者他讲到了，
情感不成熟的，
成年人的典型的前需求，
就是,
如果你真的爱我，
你应该知道，
我想让你做什么，
就这个是什么呢，
就是他，
把你跟他相处变成了，
无时无刻不存在的，
一种对你的考验，
猜猜我的心，
对，他说这里有个例子，
他说,
有一位女性说，
她的母亲，
习惯坐在书房里，
直到,
一位家人，
从厨房回来，
然后,
她就会生气的抱怨说，
这个人，
竟然没有想到，
要问她，
是否想要一杯水，
情感不成熟的人，
从不直接说，
他们想要什么，
相反,
他们会发明一个，
让每个人，
都坐立不安的，
恶性猜测游戏，
我看到这个，
我又笑了，
因为,
这就是我的，
从小到大，
我的茶叶，
虽然我，
确实不是那种，
很灵光的小孩，
但我确实，
因为,
我爸妈，
在我面前，
树立起了一个标准，
叫做,
什么是好的小孩，
好的小孩，
就是会看大人颜色的，
会去揣摩，
别人有什么需要的，
然后,
人家客人来了，
你是不是，
要适当的去，
端茶倒水啊，
你要去滴个花呀，
然后去补充瓜子啊，
然后,
你对你爸爸妈妈，
你是不是也应该这样呢，
啊,
家里没有大小的妈，
你做一个小孩，
你不应该，
你不应该做这件事情吗？
就我从小，
我就是被这样要求的，
我很少能够做到，
他们认为的，
就很完美的，
这样的一个，
被他们能称之为，
茶叶官色的，
但,
这确实就是我，
一直在玩的一种游戏，
叫做猜猜他们在想什么？
我感觉，
因为你爸妈，
特别特别需要一个，
就是我刚说的小孩，
一种那种，
社会人小孩，
嗯,
因为我的生活中，
也遇到过，
很多很多这样的，
社会人小孩，
每次当这种小孩，
出现的时候，
我们其他小孩，
即使成绩再好，
也会被比下去，
因为你就是不会看颜色，
你不会立刻，
比方说，
看见哪个叔叔站起来了，
立刻提一杯，
你也要站起来，
就是你没有这种颜色，
或者是看见，
大家不讲话了，
你就要马上出来，
表演一个，
讲个小笑话，
或者是说，
一个最近自己的小丑事，
让大家就，
哈哈哈哈，
齐乐融融，
因为我们身边，
确实是有这样的人，
指着你爸妈，
就会觉得，
为什么你，
不能是这样一个人？
就有点太忌耀又要了呢？
你忌耀我是一个，
成绩非常好，
啊，优等生，
说出去，
面上有光，
那这样的小孩，
他大概率是个书呆子，
which is me,。
我就是个书呆子，
然后你同时，
要我做一个，
就非常社会的，
然后很会搞，
这些人情事故的一个，
那你等于要求我，
既是A也是B，
在大部分人的人类的类型里面，
A和B的重合是很少很少的，
所以我就觉得，
哎呀,
你们是否有点太不知足了，
反正我爸妈，
确实也被他们的朋友，
和亲戚评价过说，
他们很不知足，
但是他们自己并不接受，
还有一个点，
我觉得非常好笑，
我看的时候就，
让我联想到了，
我自己生活中的事情，
但说情感不成熟的人，
如果做错事情了，
他们也知道自己做错事情了，
他们会希望，
你让他们尽快脱身，
如果,
因为你没有及时原谅他们，
而责备你，
会让他们好受些的话，
他们就会这么做，
他们就会说，
好了吧，
事情过去了吧，
你还不原谅，
你什么意思，
你是不是想把这个架拆散？
反正我就是，
经常会遇到这样的事情，
他讲了一个点非常好笑，
他说,
情感不成熟的人，
对于宽恕的意义，
有着一种不切实际的想法，
对他们来说，
宽恕等于让一件事情，
像是从来没有发生过，
然后重新来过，
他们不知道，
人们在遭到背叛后，
需要一定的时间，
才能重新建立信任，
他们只是想让事情，
回到以前的样子，
在他们看来，
其他人的痛苦，
是唯一的瑕疵，
所以,
如果其他人，
能够放下之前的事情，
一切都会好起来的，
哇,
你看这个想法，
多么的惦兴，
我一看我就想，
啊，是的，是的，
他们是这样想的，
所以,
我离婚的时候，
被我爸妈，
狠狠的背刺的时候，
我爸妈的态度，
就是觉得说，
为什么你不能原谅我们呢？
我们都说对不起了呀！
而且,
我就觉得，
就是这样的爸妈，
他们还有一个，
也是林赛博士讲的，
就是非常的自我矛盾，
他们有可能，
一边会跟你讲，
那个钉子的故事，
就是叫小孩，
把钉子钉到墙面上，
再把钉子取下来，
问那个小朋友说，
你看见了，
你现在看在墙上有什么，
然后小朋友说，
钉子孔，
然后爸妈会告诉你，
对，这就叫，
恶语伤人心，
虽然你讲出去的话，
讲完了就算了，
但是,
你会在墙上留下痕迹，
就像钉子钉到墙上一样，
你也会给别人心灵造成的伤害，
但是你爸妈跟你讲，
让伤人心的话的时候，
他从来不会记得这个故事，
对,
以及他会觉得，
这有什么呢？
我说说你怎么了呢？
你这个小孩怎么就心思那么重啊？
只要你什么话，
你怎么都记在心里啊？
如果你万一，
你还要跟他说，
你曾经说过什么什么，
就更起来，
你还跟不我算，
算旧账啊？
那你就完蛋，
对，因为这件事情，
又会回到，
我们之前说的那个，
家庭角色的问题上，
他们对于，
角色非常的迷恋，
就认为说，
家庭成员，
不是以人跟人之间，
在相处的，
而是以角色跟角色之间，
角色强调的是什么？
角色强调的是，
权力低位啊，
那我是父母，
你是小孩，
我的权力低位，
就是比你高，
因为这一套规矩，
它是非常明确的，
也不用去经历，
人际关系之间的那种，
复杂啊，
我们要彼此之间，
沟通,
要互相适应，
要互相去了解对方的想法，
因为这件事情，
做起来更麻烦，
需要更多的情感劳动，
那肯定是不如，
情绪传染，
就我们前面说的，
你来猜猜，
喝一杯水，
你来看我的脸色，
肯定是不如这样简单的，
所以,
你去遵守，
我是你爸，
还是你是我爸，
我是你妈，
还是你是我妈的，
这样的一套，
游戏规则的时候，
对于情感不成熟的人来说，
这样最倾聪，
他们就会非常执着，
于这件事情，
还有一个点，
我看的时候，
我觉得很有意思，
他说,
情感不成熟的父母，
希望他们的孩子，
来了解并反映他们的情绪，
如果,
他们的孩子，
不按照他们希望的方式，
做的话，
就会非常沮丧，
他们自尊太脆弱了，
然而,
没有一个孩子，
能够在心理上，
准确反映承认的情绪，
然后,
我看到这个时候，
我就有一种，
天呐,
为什么我小的时候，
没有人站出来，
替我讲这句话，
我就是不可能，
做到百分百的，
茶颜观色，
了解你在想什么，
因为你不高兴，
我就能做出一些，
恰当的举动，
让你摆脱不高兴，
或者你不高兴，
我每时每刻，
我都能发现，
因为我虽然是个小孩，
我也有小孩的生活呀，
天呐,
我就想到，
我妈给我们的测试，
虽然不是，
像你们家那种，
就是希望，
能感受到我的情绪，
我妈是那种，
我不是讲过吗，
会偷偷放一双脏袜子，
在椅背上，
看你有没有眼力见，
看到这个会去，
把他的袜子，
也洗掉的这种游戏嘛，
然后当发现，
你根本无动于中的时候，
他就会发火，
然后并且会冷笑，
就是一边，
玩着他的iPad一边，
就说,
哎呀,
家里只有我一个人，
关注到这些事，
没有一个人关心过我，
没有一个人，
注意到家里，
还有这么多家务，
我就想说，
如果你希望我们来做，
把你袜子，
洗掉这件事情，
你就可以直接讲嘛，
但是对于，
不成熟的父母来说，
还是希望，
我们刚刚说的，
你要猜猜我，
希望你在家里，
随时随地，
就是有一种，
很紧张的状态，
因为你不知道，
家里会突然发生，
一些什么事情啊，
你就要有一种，
防备的状态，
然后,
爸妈要你做的什么事，
你没有做到，
然后他还讲到了一个点，
他说，对于，
情感不成熟的人来说，
所有的互动，
都归结为，
他们是好是坏，
就这件事情是什么呢，
就是所有的事情，
都是关于他们的，
不是关于你的，
好，我这里举一个，
非常简单的例子，
就是我的离婚，
不是关于我的，
不是我离婚，
是关于我爸妈的，
女儿离婚了，
让他们丢脸了，
让他们不完美了，
在社会上有污点了，
所以,
我爸妈，
会在我离婚的时候，
直接被刺我，
这是因为，
这件事情是关于他们的，
不是关于我的，
即便,
It's my marriage,。
即便这是我的婚姻，
是我要离婚，
作者他就说，
这也解释了，
当你想和他们谈谈，
他们做过的事情的时候，
他们所表现出来的，
极度的防御心理，
哪怕是对他们行为，
极为温和的抱怨，
他们也经常用一种，
极端的话来回应，
就像是，
那好吧，
我肯定是最坏的妈呀，
行了吧，
或者说，
那我肯定是，
什么事情都做不好的，
他们宁愿结束谈话，
也不想听别人说，
让他们觉得自己是个坏人的话，
就是你跟他们，
所以你跟他们进行沟通说，
我们现在这样的方式，
对我来说，
是没有办法接受的，
会伤害我们的关系，
我希望怎么怎么样，
我们正常人沟通，
平等的沟通的话，
是这样沟通的，
但是不成熟的，
父母的耳朵里面听来，
就是说，
好，你说我是坏人，
滚,
我不要跟你谈这个，
就变成了这样子，
所以没有办法沟通，
然后说到，
家庭角色的点，
有一个作者的延伸，
我印象蛮深了，
他说就是，
因为我们刚刚已经解释了，
为什么，
情感不成熟的父母，
他会很着迷于家庭角色，
因为这套规矩非常简单，
而且利于他们，
所以他们，
既然喜欢这套游戏规则，
他们具体会怎么做呢，
叫做角色强制，
因为他会希望，
你按照他们的行为来扮演，
他们想要你扮演的角色嘛，
那作为父母，
他们就会想要，
强迫孩子，
按他们的意愿形式，
比如说，
不跟他们的孩子说话，
威胁说要抛弃小孩，
或者让其他家庭成员联合起来，
反对孩子，
那其实就是一种，
家庭内部的霸凌嘛，
那角色强制，
往往会引起对方的，
羞愧和内疚，
比如父母就会说，
自己的孩子是一个坏孩子，
仅仅是因为，
孩子想要的东西，
是他们不赞成的，
好,
朋友们，
我就想到了，
我们之前，
讨论这一类话题的时候，
包括我之前，
讲我自己，
遇到的事情的时候，
我又举了一个非常经典的例子，
叫做,
我对你太失望了，
你小的时候不是这样的，
你小的时候是很乖的，
你现在，
野了,
翅膀硬了，
不听话了，
你变成了这个样子，
去到社会外面，
血坏了，
你小时候不是这样的，
变得虚荣了，
贪目募志了，
对,
最后就归介于，
你让爸爸妈妈很失望，
然后,
这件事情，
其实我在我，
还是小孩的时候，
我就听到过这句话，
我并不像有些朋友一样，
可能是到了，
长大,
之后,
听到这句话，
因为我看到过这样的帖子，
有一种晴天疲力的感觉，
听到父母说，
我对你太失望了，
就感觉好像整个人生。
都被父母否定了，
这个事情在我身上的情况，
就是,
我已经让我的父母。
失望过很多次了，
你已经是一个，
一直被叫做，
失望的小孩的那种，
对,
我不觉得这件事情，
因为我觉得这件事情，
其实在亲子关系里面，
它是一个类似于
和武器一样的东西，
非要用的话，
那你的小孩，
最好是杀人放火了，
才能用，
我认为，
如果你的小孩，
没有做一些，
非常商天害理的事情的话，
我觉得这件事情，
都是有待商确的，
如果你还想，
跟小孩维持关系的话，
但我在我长大的过程中，
我就认为我爸妈，
经常滥用核武器，
以至于我对核武器，
虽然核武器，
不能说，
迟致今日对我毫无伤害，
但是我也已经变得，
死猪不怕开水烫了一点，
我是在讲，
蛮大以后，
听到这句话的，
那我听到这句话的时候，
可能就是，
到了我迟来的叛逆期吧，
我并不会，
被这句话，
深深伤害，
但我当然能理解，
听到这句话，
我感觉到，
被深深伤害的小孩，
我听到这句话的感觉，
差不多就，
跟我妈否定于，
我所有买的衣服，
我所有，
购买的，
跟审美有关的东西，
比方说，
我买的，
手机壳，
然后我们家，
装修的风格，
什么什么的，
就差不多的感觉吧，
我只会有一种，
你不懂，
因为我妈经常，
而且她发现，
这个核武器，
对我没有用了以后，
她会把这句话，
就是延长出去，
她会早跟远，
比方说，
你看,
你就是出去，
多大学了，
你才变成这个样子，
变得爱慕虚荣，
你就是在上海，
被这个大染缸，
给你炸坏了，
再往后一点，
发现在上海，
越变越坏，
怎么办，
她就会说，
你看看，
就是你跟你的，
哪个好朋友在一起，
她就是这样一个人，
对吧,
然后再往后伸，
你再长大一点，
跟在一起，
她又把你带坏了，
你看看，
你们变得像什么样子，
你完全不是小时候那个你了，
我真没有想到，
让你出去，
多大学，
你会变成这个样子，
妈妈太后悔，
让你出去，
我说,
这是一套组合拳，
她在你的生命中，
她是会，
她不是说打你一拳，
就算了，
她是一直会反复出现的，
然后同时，
还要攻击你身边的朋友，
就是或者是说，
你身边亲密的人，
一方面，
当然,
她是要攻击你，
你不听她话了吗，
第二个，
她要反复的强调，
就是她跟你的那个联系，
她跟你的那个情感纠缠，
她才是最紧密，
所以她要一直否定你身边的人的价值，
对,
就进行一些挑拨里间的行为，
因为如果，
在这样家庭里面长大的小孩，
因为她一直在，
原生家庭，
或者父母身上，
得不到正常的情感支持，
或者是情感连接，
她就会从别人身上去寻找嘛，
比方说，
从朋友身上，
从爱人身上，
或者是从你身边的，
哪怕是社区干部身上，
或者是老师，
从你社会里面的每一个小小的点击，
因为人就肯定是需要情感连接，
对吧,
没有一个人说好，
我这辈子就不需要情感连接，
我就这样活得很好，
不可能的，
当在这种家庭里长大的小孩，
发现了，
我有别的渠道，
可以得到我的情感支持的话，
那你就会不由自主的，
像一个树一样的，
扎根在这里，
你的根系就会蔓延到。
你的生活的所有的人，
你通过跟所有的人的连接，
得到你能够健康成长的养分，
那,
想把你只养在院子里，
你就会很害怕，
所以他要做出一些挑拨离间，
或者是希望把你其他的根都斩断，
那你就没有办法逃离他，
因为就像刚刚那个母亲说的，
我除了对你说，
我没有别人可以说了，
那他发现你不是对他说，
你可以对别人说的时候，
他就受不了了，
我妈在情绪上，
非常非常需要我的支持，
我在过去很多年里面，
我就会有一种，
我是我妈的情绪垃圾桶的感觉，
因为他跟我爸，
我从小就在听我爸妈的婚姻中的，
种种问题，
当然我爸确实一个家暴男，
他能好到哪去？
我听我妈讲这些事情的时候，
我是非常同情我妈的，
但听完了之后，
当我稍微长大一点，
我试图给我妈提出建议的时候，
就有一次我妈跟我说，
他要离婚，
杀的,
好,
我那时候已经是大学生了，
我就跟我妈非常详细的，
我认为，
好，你应该离婚，
你确实在婚姻中
过得非常的不公平，
很痛苦，
我支持你，
而且我认为，
离婚在经济上，
我妈应该得到补偿，
我就说，
那你需要什么样的支持，
你需要什么样的帮助，
我认识某位同学的家长，
他是一个律师，怎么怎么的，
我已经帮我妈想了非常多，
我坐在那里，
跟我妈进行很认真的讨论，
最后的结局就是，
我妈到第二天，
把我带去我爸的单位，
我爸就在公共场合，
也没有办法，
像在家里一样，
跟我妈在那里发作，
因为我爸在外面，
完全是一个老好人的面孔，
大家知道吗？
就是有文质丁丁的书生，
你完全不会想到
家里是一个什么样的人，
然后他就生那种
非常和爱的态度，
说，哎呦，你们怎么来了，
就那种，
哇，好像招待亲父，
好有样的那种语气，
我就,
我感觉那一瞬间，
我爸特别陌生，
他完全不在我们家庭的。
那个语境里面，
我非常意识到，
因为我妈那时候，
带着我找到我爸单位去，
明显是一个要闹事的姿态，
我爸那个态度，
是我从来没有见过的，
然后他们两个好，
他们两个去单聊了，
单聊了，那我是小孩，
我是不能在场的呀，
出来了之后，
我妈就带我回家了，
回家了之后，
我就问我妈说，
那今天，
我也不知道他们聊成什么样了，
我就说，那现在要怎么办呢，
就,
接下来我们要怎么办，
我是事务，
我和我妈是一个整体的，
我认为我是我妈的小孩，
我应该无条件的支持我妈，
所以我跟我妈商量的姿态，
是我们应该怎么办，
然后我妈这时候，
冷不定就反问了我，
也就说，你这么希望。
爸妈妈离婚吗？
就背刺你啊，
那是我，
第一次，
也不是第一次吧，
虽然小的时候，
也会存在着，
父母就会跟你说，
啊，我跟你是一伙的，
然后真的要打你骂你的时候，
就又跟你不是一伙的了，
虽然小的时候，
也发生过这种事情，
但是没有到这个程度的，
那时候真的让我一下子懵逼了，
我突然意识到就说，
我跟我妈不是，
虽然我妈经常，
爱说的一句话，
就是叫做，
我上高中之后，
她就已经把我当上。
她最好的朋友，
但方便人认为，
对，她是一直这么跟我说的，
而且她也觉得，
我们的母女关系，
就是好朋友的关系，
我那一瞬间就清醒了，
我就觉得说，
你不会这样对你的好朋友的，
你没有把我当成好朋友，
我觉得她就是献忌你啊，
因为我好朋友，
她们家的事情，
跟你虽然不一样，
但是也差不多也是被献忌了，
她是大学毕业以后，
她妈妈就是担心，
她在外面生活的怎么样啊，
有没有钱啊，
然后她就偷偷跟她妈妈说，
我工作了大概一年吧，
我现在存下来三万块钱，
但是你不要跟爸爸讲，
因为她爸爸是个独狗，
你知道吗，
一旦知道她有钱，
就会不停地追着她，
问她要钱，
然后把钱拿去赌博，
她就跟她妈妈说，
你不要告诉爸爸，
那我现在过得还不错，
我还存了三万块钱，
要什么，
就为了让她妈开心，
结果她妈转头，
就告诉她爸，
她就很痛苦，
她就跟她妈说，
你为什么要告诉爸爸呢，
我还跟你特别强调的时候，
你不要告诉她，
你告诉她，
她现在就打电话，
问我要钱了，
然后她妈是为什么呢，
她妈的心态也很简单，
她妈就是有一种，
她要在她爸爸面前，
我把小孩养得很好，
小孩现在不但工作了，
小孩还能存下三万块钱，
转头就把她给卖掉，
然后就是为了让她爸爸高兴，
为了在她爸爸面前证明，
我是个不错的妈妈，
转头就把女儿，
就是这样被刺掉，
我称之这种行为，
叫做家庭中的陷阱，
就是有一个人要陷阱掉，
那通常就是小孩啊，
其实作者说到这里呢，
当然也不是说，
遇到这种问题怎么办，
也不是要你修复父母啊，
重要的是，
我们要毕业成为
情绪独立的大人，
但是其实情绪独立。
是指一个内心的状态，
一个真正独立的人，
是要我们直面解决。
我们自己的生存困境，
尤其是在，
掐断了对父母
不切实际的期待以后，
我们还能靠自己
扛起生活的重担，
那除了那些，
要从泥巴里破土而出的。
内在动力以外呢，
还有一个，
大家不得不面对的事情，
那就是钱，
理性的财务规划，
才是最现实的东西，
也是我们获得幸福的基础，
说白了，就是要搞钱，
还要理财，
因为随时说不得底气，
比早谁依靠都来得踏实，
但是问题就好了，
我们先搞清楚了，
就是要搞钱，
那钱搞来了以后，
我们钱要怎么转，
要往哪里放呢？
积转底气的第一步，
我们要从哪里开始呢？
好，说到搞钱这个话题，
就不得不讲到，
我们既要赚钱，
也要投资吗？
那，说到投资，
就不得不提到，
我们以前，
大家买基金，
买股票的时候，
曾经有一些时候，
我们是能够赚到一些钱的，
然后那时候，
大家都会觉得，
那投资理财是正道嘛，
比如说，
你买了股票，
什么的，
一个月的工资，
一个下午的涨停就出来了，
结果，好，
近些年，
股市基金，
服服成成，
无论你是买哪个，
你都已经可能笑不出来，
反正我是笑不出来，
然后我们这时候，
就开始羡慕那种，
耐得住诱惑，
连你的投资，
账户都没有开的朋友，
经过亏了那么多钱之后，
我充分意识到了，
我确实是一个风险，
厌无形的人，
只不过我以前，
没有认清我自己，
我现在就是感觉，
比如说你手头，
宽欲又灵活的钱钱，
充一充没什么，
但是,
你的地盘呢，
尤其是自己未来的，
养老钱，
就必须是要保本和稳健的，
所以我们现在，
买的产品，
就大部分是，
商业保险，
比如说，
重级险医疗险，
重健康险，
也有,
养老年金，
增额终身之类的，
储蓄险，
相比,
基金股票呢，
保险是肯定不可能，
让你爷抱负的，
这个是肯定，
然后呢，
它也不会让你，
就此实现，
财务自由，
但它就是有一种，
让你自己，
还有你的可能，
家里人吧，
都觉得会，
比较踏实的，
这是一种，
确定性的保障，
对,
大家可能会想说，
哎呀,
你讲的太复杂了，
什么,
我就把钱，
放在银行，
不就好了吗？
这点呢，
其实我觉得很多，
大家在看，
各种投资博主的时候，
就已经看过好，
首先呢，
你要保证，
你省下来，
这些钱，
也能真正的，
放到银行，
你能存住，
而不是花掉，
其次呢，
你存的钱，
几十年，
不变的利率，
要知道，
现在连国有大银行，
都做不到，
几十年，
利率不变，
因为现在连年降息嘛，
几年前呢，
还有三点多的利息，
现在基本上，
就是一点几，
我的天呐，
一点几的利息，
大家知道吗，
如果你今年，
去水果摊上，
你买那个国产，
黄鹰桃，
比去年，
涨价都不止涨，
一点几，
但是呢，
保险不一样，
其实保险，
在我们购买的时候，
合同里，
其实已经，
每年呢，
他按多少掌，
然后每年呢，
领多少钱，
因为国内的财富显呢，
都是由国家兜地保障的，
利率一旦定下，
终身就不会变，
他是受到，
金融部门严格的监管的，
也就是说，
就算保险公司，
他自己出事倒闭了，
我们的保单，
也会被其他人接受，
合同保证的部分，
也会足够兑现的，
也就是说，
保险公司必须，
按合同给你钱，
这些其实，
都是已经约定好的，
他自己买的那个，
年金显，
就是每年繳钱，
存购固定的年数，
就可以一次性地取出来，
当然你也可以说，
我像,
那个家族基金一样，
每个月领一次，
最重要的就是，
你活多久领多久，
相当于他一个，
跟你生命的，
岁数等长的现金流，
所以呢，
我们现在要做的就是，
活的长长久久，
多活就能多分点钱，
多能领到这个年金，
然后除了刚刚，
验说那一种呢，
其实还有增额终身寿，
大家如果听过这个名词，
反正就是，
听不懂他啥意思嘛，
其实他的逻辑更简单，
就是把现在的钱，
所在一个存钱罐里面，
最大的不同是，
他可以让，
本金不断的富力长大，
加上被合同，
锁定了的终身利率，
他就是只增不减的，
相当于一个，
不会缩水，
还可以自己，
把自己养肥的存钱罐，
如果你是，
觉得,
我对养老，
不太感兴趣，
我只想每个月，
被动的零点，
零花钱呢，
还可以选快返年金，
同样是活多久领多久，
但他最快是第五年，
就可以领钱，
然后还有，
分红星保底，
同样是写金合同，
盈利了呢，
还会参与分红，
简单理解就是，
不会降息的存折，
外挂一笔分红，
是不是差别还是蛮大的，
尤其是财富钱，
比如说，
你有一笔储蓄，
想一次新交亲，
和你每个月，
想慢慢存，
大家情况不一样，
适合的可能就不一样，
那你的年龄也会很关键，
所以大家如果感兴趣的话呢，
就建议找专业的人，
先问清楚，
那问谁呢？
好，当然又是我们的老朋友，
小雨散啦，
相信很多朋友，
也比较熟悉他们，
跟很多传统的保险公司不同，
小雨散是专业的保险经济平台，
是由国家金融监管总局，
批准成立的，
作为中立的第三方，
他能帮你把产品，
放在同一个栏子里，
做横向对比和筛选，
而且和顾问的所有沟通，
无论是企业微信，还是电话，
都会受到监督，
就不用担心，
会为了卖产品而夸大其词，
恰恰相反，
保险顾问都很专业，
会详细的问你现在的收入，
还有资产配置情况，
对未来的规划，期许，
还有你的风险偏好等等，
最后让你在掌握
全部信息的情况下，
再做决定，
这点就是非常好，
还没有配置过呢，
又怕买错的朋友，
都可以预约一个
小雨伞的顾问，
先聊一聊，
反正咨询只要一分钱，
我们会把详细的链接。
放在shownotes里,。
最后私心提醒一句，
向年金和真额终身受险，
如果你设计好了，
指定受益人和投保结构的话，
你的财富还可以实现，
定向转移，隔离风险，
任何想动你坏脑金的人，
很难分手你的钱，
具体怎么样操作呢，
我觉得大家还是可以。
跟保险顾问聊一聊。
除此之外，
大家还可以免费投保，
一分薄额一万元的。
女性妨碍险，
包括乳陷癌，
攻减癌等
七种高发癌症，
确诊级配，
以及一份
三万元的成人意外保障，
直接找顾问就可以领取。
好，那让我们
继续回到本期
节目的讨论。
然后作者他提到了。
一点,
就是说，
为什么？
情感不成熟的人，
他会反复无常，
因为我们刚刚说的。
这个问题很明显，
就是叫做反复无常吗？
他前脚跟你说一句话，
后脚他就不是这样做的，
为什么呢？
是因为不成熟的人，
被感压力
或情绪激动的时候，
他们不会觉得
自己身处时间的洪流中，
他们有一个问题叫做，
他们缺乏连续的时间管年，
他们觉得
自己经历的时刻
是互相孤立的，
没有什么联系，
所以当他们的意识。
不断转换的时候，
行为也就变得反复无常，
所以,
当你提醒他们
过去的行为的时候，
他们就会生气，
当你说你之前不是这么说的，
因为对他们来说，
过去的事情过去了，
跟现在有什么关系？
那未来的事情，
那明天的事情，
谁知道，
跟现在有什么关系？
所以,
他们不追求
你的人要保持一个遗关性，
你过去说的和现在说的，
你是要相对的一致的，
他们也不觉得说，
我需要，
因为你这样做这个事情，
你对小孩
势必会造成困惑，对吧？
他也不觉得
你应该对这种困惑负责人，
所以,
他们这个时间观念的不连续，
导致他们对于因果，
也是不连续的，
所以呢，
他们也没有办法理解，
当你被他们伤害了，
你感觉受到了背叛，
很痛苦的时候，
为什么不原谅他们？
因为过去的事情，
已经过去了呀！
所以,
这件事情到最后，
我们会发现，
我们讲的很多事情，
就好像，
所有东西都连在了一起，
都会绕回去，
绕到另外一个话题上面去，
都是因为，
所有的背后的逻辑，
都是这样，
联系在一起的，
他这个前后矛盾，
非常有意思的，
就他形成了一种，
因为反复无常，
到至于小孩，
不知道做什么东西，
才是正确的，
产生了一种，
大家通常在古装距离，
能够看到的情形，
叫做军威难测，
就是,
知道,
爸爸到底是高兴，
还是不高兴，
还是现在高兴，
等会儿就不高兴了，
以及,
你明明做的是，
一样的事情，
你有可能获得不同的结果，
同样一件事情，
可能今天爸爸表扬你了，
明天爸爸说，
什么玩意儿，
又可能发生这样的事情，
然后他就讲说，
行为心理学家，
趁这种情况，
为见解性奖励，
意思是，
你会为自己付出，
得到一些奖励，
但这种奖励，
你是无法预测的，
纯粹看，
今天爸爸妈妈，
心情是不是好，
或者是，
你今天这件事，
是否做到她的心坎上，
或者是，
她今天，
本来就心情好，
你做什么都是对的，
我会觉得，
这个事情是很典型的，
也就是说，
其实你在家庭里面，
你是没有一个，
就像我们刚刚说的，
是非正确方面，
你也没有一个疑惯性，
你不知道什么事情，
它就是对的，
或者就是错的，
因为正确的是，
和错误的事情，
它在某种程度上，
跟一加一等于二是一样的，
一加一不可能有一天，
不等于二嘛，对吧，
但是在家庭里，
就很难讲，
我觉得这个也会给，
小朋友，
就是生活在这样的家庭里面，
产生一些困惑，
就是我永远不知道，
事情是不是对的，
或者是，
我这样做，
是不是合理的，
爸妈妈是不是高兴的，
我就觉得，
你会产生一些是非混乱，
或者是一些，
长大了以后，
还是不晓得这件事情，
就是你有可能，
在家里做这些事情，
让爸妈高兴，
你在外面做这件事情，
可能就是错的嘛，
也有可能，
你会把这个事情，
同样的，
在其他小朋友身上做，
然后就会被打，
而且,
你刚才讲这个时候，
我就想到，
我妈很爱跟我讲一句话，
叫做,
家里不是讲道理的地方，
当我试图跟我妈讲，
说,
这件事情，
这样是不对的，
比如说，
爸爸这样是在伤害你，
是在伤害我，
所以,
我们不应该，
让这个不公平的情况，
继续发生，
我们应该，
就想一些办法，
来支持他这样做，
什么什么的，
然后他就说，
那这样吵来吵去，
有什么意义呢？
家里不是讲道理的地方，
最后,
大家所有人都搞得不愉快，
干什么呢？
我妈就会，
在这种场景里面，
因为用这个话，
即便我提出的那个，
方案,
可能是有离语他的，
但是我妈可能觉得说，
实实起来，
太困难了，
或者怎么样，
就他已经放弃了，
几句,
家里不是讲道理的地方，
包括他们伤害我，
最终也会变成，
一个家里不是讲道理的地方，
就所有一切，
都是被糊弄过去了，
所以我在，
我的家庭之外，
跟我父母的关系之外，
我是非常不喜欢，
人际关系之中，
是糊弄的，
我觉得没有讲不清楚的，
只有不愿意讲清楚，
或者说，
大家没有，
能力,
把自己到底，
是怎么想的，
想清楚，
那是另外一回事，
但是很多时候，
是一个意愿的问题，
然后,
你刚说那个，
半君如半虎，
天呐,
到我上大学之前，
我,
整个成长经历，
就是有一种，
我一直在做如臣，
如家的臣子的那个，
我对于，
天地君亲师，
君君臣臣，
父父子子，
三缸五长的那些东西，
首先我从小，
我确实接受古典教育，
我就背这些东西，
而且,
我爸妈也是那种，
他们受的教育，
也是那种文人，
尤其是我爸的，
价值观念的，
取向,
他是那种，
世大夫的价值观念，
所以,
我们家的，
整体的氛围，
文学上，
我接受这样的一个，
古典教育，
娱乐上，
我们看，
康熙王朝，
庸正王朝，
我们家就在看，
宫廷剧，
全谋剧，
看,
普通人怎么伺候皇帝，
皇帝如何玩弄权术，
哇，我爸看的，
那叫一个入迷，
而且,
我经常感觉到，
我爸看完了之后，
要在家里施展一番，
虽然他没有直接这么说，
我一直觉得，
我对于我爸的那种，
东西叫做伺候，
叫做,
我在侍奉皇上，
我从小到大，
一直在做这件事情，
就这样，
所以我对于，
如臣,
汉臣,
这些东西，
哇，我太熟悉了，
我就感觉，
我虽然，
没有去，
上过朝，
当过官，
但是我已经，
当了十八年的，
臣子,
或者说，
你的功能还蛮强的，
对，我的功能其实，
超级强，
我每当想到，
这个事情的时候，
我就会有一种，
我以后有一种，
淡淡的悲哀，
因为我爸妈，
甚至不觉得，
他们在欺负小孩，
他们就会觉得，
就是这样的，
而且是这样的吗，
还觉得，
我是在培养你，
你进入社会，
迟早要用到这个技能，
爸妈妈，
提早就培养你，
会查言官色，
以后,
你到了单位里面，
你知道吗，
其他人都没有这个，
这种优待，
而你从小，
就经过了这样的培训，
对，他们就觉得说，
这就是一种，
社会的固有规则，
而且,
他们给我的教育里面，
有很多都会，
也是一种，
包括,
我爸也明确说，
我就是中南情侣，
如果你是儿子，
我肯定是换一种，
我要更加严格要求你，
他们对于，
这一套的教育方式，
叫做严格要求，
所以,
我不是不能理解，
他们角度，
来看这件事情，
他们是怎么看的，
他们认为，
这个叫做，
严格教育的一部分，
但实际上，
它是一种，
关于服从的教育，
并不是说，
关于你这个人的，
培养的教育，
然后我们，
再倒退回去，
当我长大的之后，
我爸妈的一些，
很多东西的时候，
我就会觉得说，
其实他们，
很多事情的处理方式，
是非常不成熟的，
而且,
他们,
虽然,
我可以说，
也许他们大部分时候，
不是出于，
我就要折腾你这个孩子，
我是恶意的，
我要搞死你，
但是,
他确实很多时候，
采取了一种，
熬音的方式，
就会比如说，
我跟我爸妈之间，
我被认为，
不够听我爸妈的话，
就是罚柜嘛，
一直柜在那儿，
或者打我嘛，
然后在这个过程中，
就会说，
还瞪，还瞪，
然后再打，
这不就是一种，
熬音的方式嘛，
就,
身体上的虐待，
加上情绪上的压制，
而且不许我哭，
哭,
也是代表你不顺从，
你如果顺从了，
你为什么连哭都认不住，
然后,
而且我哭的时候，
就会说，
你这样瞪我们，
干什么，
你还有点哭？
我觉得好像，
哭这件事情，
家长的反应都很大，
可能是觉得，
哭,
这个事情，
就是因为，
当你婴儿是哭的时候，
他就要进行哄这个动作，
所以,
哭对于，
这种不成熟的家长来，
也变成了一个，
条件反射，
因为我觉得，
我爸妈已经，
虽然也是不成熟的家长，
但是,
其他的程度，
比方说，
家暴什么的，
就没有你们家这么严重，
可是他对于，
比方说，
小孩哭，
就比方说，
我哭这件事情，
他们就反应，
就是非常大，
就比方说，
他骂你，
他打你，
你可以，
认错,
但你不可以哭，
你一旦哭了，
门外,
你知道那个时候，
我大概才，
八九岁吧，
你知道，
小孩晚上在门外，
你说说有多惊恐啊，
而且是冬天晚上，
他就,
当然他不说，
赶紧出去，
他就叫你在门外站着，
然后把门关掉了，
你已经很害怕了，
因为,
你知道，
小孩对小孩来说，
黑夜寒冷，
冬日的夜晚，
你就会觉得，
你就要死掉了，
就会被鬼吃掉，
类似你会产生，
像这样的恐惧嘛，
然后对我来说，
就是非常害怕，
我觉得外面，
放生大哭，
然后只有到你哭到，
就是,
那时候我已经哭到累了，
你知道我哭到什么程度吗，
我后面三天长的那个，
脉利肿，
就是哭成那个样子，
然后我妈，
她一直要听到我的外面，
哭到没有声音啊，
她才会开门，
她就认为你好，
你终于止住哭声了，
你不哭了，
这件事情才可以往下走，
你要哭了的话，
就是你只会越来越惨，
就是你只会越来越倒霉，
我觉得是，
可能,
因为哭本身就是一种，
反抗嘛，
你哭什么，
你就是委屈嘛，
就是你的错，
因为我们家打小孩，
就是我放生大哭的话，
邻居会下来温的，
这是一个丢脸的事情，
对吧,
遇而无方，
显得我们就是水平不够，
是的,
所以你就会很自然的，
那就小孩就不许哭嘛，
你要表示绝对的顺从，
服从,
行为上矫正了，
态度也要矫正，
哭就是一种态度的不服从，
不过我是，
我是感觉到现在的那个家长，
好像对这一点还蛮好，
因为我在小红书上经常看到，
分享就是说，
当小孩哭的时候，
那，妈妈要允许小朋友哭，
因为哭是一种情绪的发泄啊，
我就觉得，
大家的那个遇而观念，
在慢慢的矫正，
因为我妈，
对于大概十年前，
我外申女还是婴儿的时候，
我外申女现在上大学嘛，
是婴儿的时候，
也是,
她要哭，
我妈就会，
不由自主的拿出她那一套，
并且交给我姐姐，
就是,
不要让小孩哭，
这种错误的遇而观念，
但我感觉到现在好，
有一种，
欣慰感，
就是我们还是有一点点的进步，
然后我们刚刚说了那么多，
其实,
作者,
她把,
情感不成熟的父母，
她是分成了四个类型，
我觉得，
她分类，
也分得，
非常方便，
让我们去，
对好如作，
但是,
作者也说了，
因为,
四种类型的，
情感不成熟的父母，
他们是有存在，
一些共同的特质的，
就会导致说，
你可能觉得说，
A也好像有点像，
B也好像有点像，
那确实有可能，
你的父母在这方面，
有点交叉，
也有可能，
是因为，
你遇到的问题，
就是四类父母里面，
他们都会具有的，
一些共性的问题，
所以你会觉得，
都很像，
但是,
其实还好，
也不至于说，
完全分不出来，
我们可以简单讲一下，
是四类哪几种类型，
我觉得我们，
因为这本书的内容，
其实还是蛮多的，
我们也不可能，
都跟大家讲，
就是,
只能提纲切领的，
跟大家大致的，
分一下类，
对,
第一类呢，
叫做情绪型父母，
他们呢，
是,
特别容易受情绪支配，
他们经常会，
在过分纠缠，
和突然退出之间，
就两极的震荡，
他们的特点，
叫做,
可怕的不稳定性，
和不可预测性，
一旦他们焦虑了，
好,
就要依靠别人来安抚他们，
或者让小孩来安抚他们，
对待一些很小的，
麻烦事情，
对待世界末日一样，
就会把，
其他人当作他们的救世主，
或者,
抛弃者，
你要是来救我，
你就说我的救世主，
如果你不管我，
你就是抛弃我了，
所以,
情绪型父母，
听起来就非常像，
孩子,
对,
因为我妹妹她的，
六娃搭子的那个，
那个家庭，
就是这样，
尤其是我有一次，
听我妹讲，
那个我都震惊了，
因为小孩就是会哭闹嘛，
婴儿哦，
婴儿,
我要跟大家，
强调,
她是婴儿，
是完全没有办法，
在哭闹，
哭到不停的时候，
那,
我觉得普通的家长，
正常的，
你要不然，
就是抱起来，
哄一哄啊，
然后看一看，
小孩的需求啊，
比方说，
她是不是，
冷了热啦，
热了渴啦，
或者是尿床啦，
拉屎拉到啦，
那就是，
爸妈应该做的嘛，
那也有可能小孩，
她就,
任何原因都没有，
她就是不高兴，
或她不舒适，
但她那个不舒适，
还没有办法表达，
她就是会哭，
那,
正常家长，
她就是非常的好笑，
她一开始，
就是会喝赤小孩说，
不要哭了，
但是你想，
嬰儿怎么可能听得懂，
你说不要哭了，
然后嬰儿就继续哭，
然后她就怎么办呢，
哇，她做错那个行为，
我就是哈哈大笑，
她就像另一个孩子，
她就,
真的就是像动画片里，
我们看到，
她用那个两个手，
堵住自己的耳朵眼，
然后开始，
拉拉拉拉拉拉，
来,
盖过手，
她就哭声，
然后她就听不到小孩哭了，
是不是，
非常可怕，
你听上去，
想说,
我妹妹就说，
哇，她看见她这样子，
她就是觉得，
你怎么，
她不像一个，
对吧,
让我们说，
不像一个成人，
做出来的举动，
她就是这样的一个父母，
然后有的时候，
她会跟小孩互相嗆声，
互相堵气，
现在她小孩，
当然已经四五岁了，
已经稍微长大了一点，
但是他们的相处模式，
仍然有一种，
就是说，
你才讨厌鬼，
什么什么的，
就相处起来，
虽然看上去，
她经常说，
我儿子是我最好的朋友，
但是你就会有一种对，
最好的朋友，
但是你们都是幼儿园的朋友，
那种感受。
作者在情绪型父母里面，
他举了一个例子，
他说,
因为他们情感波动，
特别大嘛，
而且基本上，
就会把自己视为受害者，
就让别人，
需要一直去，
产严观色，
关注他们的需求和感受。
他们在家庭关系中，
有一个非常典型的表现，
叫做很冲动，
尤其是在喝醉的时候，
他们毫无顾忌的行为，
着实,
让人震惊，
喝醉这两个字，
哇，我一下就被触发关键词，
然后我就想，天哪，爸爸，
这是你，
好无奈，
因为我，
实在从小到大，
看到我爸喝醉过太多次，
我爸就是那种喝醉了要点煤气，
把全家扎掉，
让所有人跟他一起死的那种难道。
好恐怖啊，
我记得那次是因为，
我爸在那里就喝酒，
然后,
又在那里发泄，
他的心中的不愉快，
我实在看不下去了，
在那里，
因为越喝越多之后，
情绪越来越失控，
我那时候应该十来岁吧，
我就去把我爸的酒杯躲下来，
让我爸不要再喝了，
你看我这时候，
已经在扮演一个，
好小孩的形象了哦，
我已经在干预我爸妈的行为了，
我已经在做这样的事情了，
但是我爸就是那种，
瞪着眼，
骂我,
就是说让你管，
怎么怎么怎么，
你还来管我，
你还管老子，
他说你越这样，
我越要喝，
然后就又拿出，
因为我爸是喝白酒的，
他又拿出那一个，
一大缸的那个白酒，
往那个他那酒杯里面倒，倒满，
什么的，
我一看到他这样，
我就觉得，
我觉得你好搞笑啊，
你在这跟我讲什么，
是我惹你的吗？
我那时候，
因为我从小到大，
虽然我一直被我爸妈这样教育，
但是我也并不是一个，
让他们挫变，
柔方的一个小孩，
我要是这样的话，
我现在也长不到这么大，
朋友们，
我也是，
在这种环境下，
我也成长出了，
由我自己主心鼓的，
一个很强硬的性格，
然后我看我爸这样，
就在你发风发得更来劲之后，
我不仅披手夺过，
然后我爸就跟我争强起来了，
在好像发展到后面，
我就直接把我爸的那个酒杯，
拿过来，
摔到了地上，
把他酒杯给砸了，
哇，我爸一看到我砸酒杯，
他就,
哇塞,
立刻开始发风啊，
他就觉得说，
你连我酒杯都敢砸，
你是,
他那种，
充满了那种，
对,
他就充满了那种，
你犯上作乱，
大逆不道，
你要那个，
是君是妇，
我爸立刻进入了那种，
表演情境你知道吗？
我,
很明显感觉到我爸，
他本来喝醉了之后，
人就非常的夸张，
言行非常夸张，
我又要说了朋友们，
我爸在家庭之外，
表现出来的，
可是一个叫做，
温文尔亚的人哥，
哇,
他在他的单位里面，
他的同事，
他的朋友，
可能很难想象他在家里，
是这个样子的，
然后我爸就在那里，
我一看我爸那样，
更来劲了之后，
哇，我爸，
其实我是被我爸吓到了，
我已经没有办法再靠近他，
因为我觉得我在靠近他，
再跟他进一步起，
正面冲突，
我就被他打了，
然后我就退出来一步之后，
我看我爸在那儿独自发飙，
在那儿表演，
还有在那儿说什么，
好,
我现在，
谁都能来管我，
你女儿，
你算什么东西，
你都能来管我，
我喝酒都没有办法喝，
这个日子没有办法过了，
我现在就把媒体点起来，
我们全家一起去死，
反正老婆也是我的，
女儿也是我的，
我们一起死好了，
哇，我爸就开始这样子，
然后我当时就有一种，
我立刻意识到了，
其实,
虽然我之前就这么觉得，
我爸认为他是这个家里的皇帝，
但是在我爸说出那一句话的时候，
我非常深刻地意识到，
他认为我和我妈的生命是属于他的，
天呐，他就是，
那种,
如果在美国家里可以持墙，
他死之前要把全家杀光的那种，
对,
但是反过来说，
但反过来说，
我也认为在一个
相对法治正常的国家，
我爸可能进展不到这样的一个程度，
或者他如果进展到这个程度，
他已经被抓了，
对，他可能很久就被抓，
因为他打你的时候，
他就已经被抓走了，
我想到我另外一个朋友，
他爸爸就是差不多，
他们是全家一起出去旅行，
然后在，
已经准备要去机场，
大家都已经穿戴好了，
他已经要去机场，
叫的车都已经快到门口的时候，
他爸突然发现，
他妹妹穿的裙子，
不符合他爸爸的要求，
然后叫他妹妹换裙子，
他妹说天呐，
都已经，
要快出门了，
而且这裙子有什么问题呢？
然后他爸就，
开始躺在沙发上说不走了，
然后他就说，
车都已经到了，
你现在说不走了，
他爸就说，
我觉得没有什么意思，
现在这种旅行，
我觉得觉得没有什么意思，
就是他没有旅行，
已经开始不高兴了，
那我不知道旅行有什么意思，
就不走就躺在沙发上，
就开始赖死，
我会觉得我的天呐，
就是我一看到说，
那种情绪型的，
不成熟父母，
我就马上想到了这样，
他的那个，
他的爹，
他就是这样的，
就是全家一定要以他的心情，
我每到这个时候，
我就会想，
同时社会还在告诉我们，
男的情绪比女的稳定，
这在我的成长经历中，
我看到的完全不是这样子的，
当我看到我妈发疯的时候，
我妈也是被逼疯的，
那我真的很同情我妈，
我想说，
男的情绪比女的稳定，
是因为女的都在维护，
男的情绪稳定啊，
对吧?
对啊，这个社会，
本来就是对男的更友好啊，
而且,
在男的发疯的时候，
大家就会觉得，
他是被逼到不行了，
他才这样的，
他又会获得更大的宽容，
对，你说一个人被逼成啥样，
才会什么，
才会什么，烧死全家一样，
就会来理解他了。
那来讲第二种，
第二种父母，
叫驱动型的父母，
驱动型父母是，
四类父母中看起来最正常的，
因为他非常非常愿意，
为自己的孩子投资，
就是简而言之，
他会给你抱两百个，
课外般的那种，
父母,
林塞博士说，
驱动型父母非常关注，
自己孩子的成功，
他们的自我中心主义，
是很难察觉的，
大多数时候，
你不会觉察到，
他们身上不健康的特点，
然而他们的小孩，
却可能就是，
比如说缺乏主动性，
和自我控制能力，
这就会让人觉得很矛盾，
哇,
勤奋的父母最终培养，
除了失去动力，
甚至有些异域的孩子，
我感觉这个还，
蛮经常看到的吧，
这就是我们经常看到的，
一种就是什么虎妈，
什么狼爸，
你把它换成这样的词语，
大家就会马上意识到，
其实这种人在你身边，
就是很多的，
那他为什么不成熟呢？
就是这种不成熟体现在，
他们对其他人做出的假设，
也就是说，
他根本不关心小孩，
真正喜欢什么，
或者是真正想要什么，
他们希望每个人，
跟他们做一样的事情，
这种过度的自我集中，
表现为他们了解，
什么叫做为你好，
很简单就是这样，
就比较说，
他们会觉得，
小孩，你有什么爱好，
你有爱好有什么用呢？
这最近你的高考有帮助吗？
他能在你的高考中给你加分吗？
或者是说，
他能让你找到一份好工作吗？
他能让你升职加薪吗？
他能让你跟你的领导关系，
更进一步吗？
我感觉很多东西，
他们就会用自己的，
现有的社会经验，
或者是非常世俗的，
那种成功的经验，
来以这个要求你，
比方说，
你只要是个学校好的孩子，
那就,
我们一切都不管你了，
你只要成绩好，
我们的投资，
也是只为了你成绩好，
他给你包那么多课外班，
也是为了让你比方说，
许多考五分，
他的课外班，
可不是说让你去骑马什么？
Maybe也有骑马，
那他培养你的方向，
可能就是另外一个，
就是你要成为某种意义上的，
名门，书员，
这样类似的，
那他可能会给你
包一些礼仪课，
那也一切是，
以他们的目标为准，
而不是你的意愿为准。
因为他们整体来说，
就是想要完成更多的KPI，
就是这样一种，
KPI驱动型的人吗？
他们会觉得说，
目标比人更重要，
尤其是这个人指的是什么呢？
就是你，
实现目标比你的感受更重要。
这样的父母，
他们外表看起来，
就会觉得说，
他们自己就很厉害啊，
因为他们会靠自己努力啊，
什么的。
作者说，
驱动型父母通常是在一个。
情感被剥夺的环境中长大的，
所以他们是先靠了自己努力，
不期望有人会愿意培养他们，
他们自己可能自治力就很强，
为自己的独立而感到自豪，
所以他们会特别担心，
那我的小孩，
作为我掛剑，
作为我附属的一部分，
如果我的小孩不成功的话，
我会很尴尬。
但是,
他们又不会无条件的满足。
孩子的请求，
来帮助孩子们
实现他们的目标，
无论他们是不是故意的，
驱动型父母会让孩子。
觉得自己时刻
都在接受父母的考量，
然后他举了一个例子，
他说有个爸爸，
就是让孩子们
在他面前练习钢琴，
这样的话，
他就会在旁边盯着，
可以指出他们的错误，
然而这种过渡的监管，
往往会让孩子厌倦，
寻求成年人的帮助，
在成年以后
也会导致亲子关系很疏离，
然后他还举了一个例子，
非常好笑，
他说约翰的故事，
他大概就说，
他爸妈就是这样的。
一种KPA怪吧，
很驱动型的，
他甚至不说，
你要实现什么人生目标了，
他对你的情绪，
他都要管控，
他说,
在他们一家人度假的时候，
如果这个小孩玩得不够高兴，
他的父亲就会很生气，
就不只是说你在生活上，
你要达到某些目标，
你在情绪上也要符合他对你的那个期待，
不然的话，
其实对他来说，
这个东西就失控了嘛，
然后他又举了另外一个女生的故事，
就克里斯丁，
他说,
他的爸爸是一个老师，
他不知道一个孩子，
可能会对一些事情感到害怕，
当他爸爸试图教他游泳的时候，
实际上并没有教什么，
仅仅是把这个小女孩。
扔到了一个泳池里面，
完全不顾孩子的感受，
这个女生他就说，
她会命令我好好做，
但没有提供任何指导。
或帮助，
我只是被她要求成功而已，
从表面上来看，
克里斯丁的确成功了，
就他学会游泳，
但是他内心里面，
他是有着强烈的不安感，
他真的不知道自己在做什么，
然后想到天呐，
克里斯丁，你爸也是我爸，
我刚想说你爸就是混和型，
对，我爸就是混和型，
因为我爸我妈都是那种，
认为自己在自己的生活里面。
做得非常的好，
他们也认为自己是鲤鱼跳龙门了，
已经突破了自己父母所在的那个环境，
所以他们会认为自己的人生。
已经过得很成功了，
也要求我必须要过一个。
他们认为的成功的人生，
所以在我的人生目标上，
他们当然就会干涉很多，
我的人生选择，
我的私人生活里面，
他们也会干涉很多，
因为他们认为，
一定有一条最标准的，
最完美的道路，
在那里，
如果我不结婚，
或者我不生小孩，
包括我离婚，
都是破坏了这条道路上的。
种种辩量，
导致我做了令他们羞耻的事情，
让他们的脸上蒙羞，
让他们的人生多了一个污点，
在总体的我的人生路上，
我爸妈的表现，
然后我刚说那个游泳的那个事情，
就那个女生说的，
她爸把她扔到水里面，
就是命令你给我学会游泳，
但是她又不是说具体教，
你要怎么样学会游泳，
我就觉得说，
天呐，我就看到了我爸的影子，
因为在我上学的过程中，
我爸，我妈，
他们都没有仔仔细细的，
就是说坐在我旁边，
扶到我写作业，
或怎么样都从来都没有，
而且他们很自豪于这件事情，
就觉得说，
因为我的小孩很聪明，
他学习是不用我操心的，
你看，多厉害，
我们就，是我们家教，
教得好吧，
小孩也聪明，
听话，乖，
所以呢，我们是很省心的，
这是我爸妈认为，
他们教育很成功的一个论句，
但是这个事情，
总是会有一些，
有变化的时候，
我也不可能，
永远都考全校第一吧，
所以就有一次，
我数学考得非常差，
那个差是差到了，
那我及格还是及格的，
但是是在我的，
整个的，
上学考试的期间，
我的数学考得最差的一次，
大概可能，
差到了我们班的中游吧，
因为我是，
全校第一考进去的，
我一旦，
差到了中游之后，
我爸崩溃了，
我爸从我妈那里，
听到,
这件事情之后，
他在家里面，
就开始，
长许短探，
那首先，
骂我也是骂我的，
然后第二件事情呢，
叫做,
斥责我妈，
没有把我教好，
我不知道为什么，
我爸认为，
对,
把小孩他没有责任，
我爸认为，
我们家的结构是这样子，
叫做,
他是这个家的领导，
他高屋建邻，
发表一些方向性的指导，
我妈呢，
具体执行，
把小孩，
养养好，
我爸认为，
他在这个家的角色，
叫做,
抓大放小，
但是他抓了什么大，
我也不知道好，
所以在那个过程中，
就是一边骂我，
一边骂我妈，
那我爸在这件事情，
相当于是，
我不会游泳，
或者说，
我游泳的不好，
我爸的表现叫做，
你给我好好游，
但是,
他并不会下到水里面来，
或者站在岸边，
看你到底哪里游的不好，
怎么样，
他不会提供任何帮助的，
他就会骂你，
为什么不会游，
你爸本人有的怎么样，
你说我爸的学习表现吗，
就游泳，
我不知道，
我爸应该，
我爸应该会游泳吧，
他是在长江里面游泳的那种人，
OK,
所以他就是认为，
我有资格指导你，
是不是，
并不是说，
我刚刚说的这个游泳，
是一个比喻的游泳，
因为是前面那个，
克里斯丁的例子里面，
他是,
他的那个事情是一个游泳的例子，
那如果你在学术上的表现的话，
显然,
我的学术成绩，
在我求学的过程中，
我百分百是比我爸牛逼的呀，
但是,
并不阻碍，
我爸认为，
我做的不好，
丢了他的脸，
或者,
我应该，
自己把自己管理好，
说到这里，
我又想到了，
我在我们家，
最重要的一个工作，
叫做,
赞美,
上西,
我爸的文学素养，
因为,
加进皇帝高出来的，
你还为他，
亲自写一篇，
阅读理解，
因为我爸，
我妈是那种，
书法也非常厉害，
就是他们确实在，
文学,
或者文艺方面，
他们的个人修养，
很搞好，
他们也是会拿奖的那种，
也不能说，
他们是那种，
让别人硬垮，
但是呢，
我爸在家里，
夸奖他们，
赏实他们，
是我作为孩子的职责，
同时我爸，
也会搞一些，
诗词创作，
我爸是一个，
格律师的诗人，
而且他，
所以我爸，
所以我说，
我爸是个如生，
他,
不是一句夸张的话，
我爸就是一个如生，
他确实是，
一个世大夫的，
要求来，
要求自己的，
他的自我定位，
也是那个样子的，
所以当他写一些，
比如说，
我爸还会写那种，
副,
什么,
就是填词作副的时候，
他就要把他的文本拿过来，
让我进行一个赏西，
进行一个，
哪个字写的好，
哪句话写的好，
让我进行一个，
实际上就是，
让我进行一个吹捧啊，
虽然,
我作为小孩，
因为我小时候，
我前面也说了，
我在我们家，
也接受了一个古典的教育，
而且我爸妈在这方面，
他们是，
认为我是有赏西水平的，
所以才会，
让我做这件事情，
而且我从小，
我的赏西水平，
确实就还可以，
我说出来，
都是一些，
就是不是硬吹，
但是,
这里面存在一个权力关系啊，
是你的领导，
让你,
评论他的文章，
你能说不好吗？
反正我是不能说不好的，
我只能说，
比如说我硬要说，
他写了五首诗，
我可能觉得，
四首都非常的一般，
那我也不能说，
这四首很一般，
我只能挑出，
我觉得最好的那一首，
最好的那句话，
拿出来说，
我最喜欢这一首，
你知道吗，
在这个过程中，
非常多的，
奉承我爸的话述，
然后巧妙地隐藏，
你对于他，
认为,
认为我爸写的，
不好的那些话的真实意见，
那肯定是不能讲的，
然后这个关系，
我认为，
我爸在这个过程中，
他认为，
这个东西是一个，
平等的交流，
或者,
我不知道他有没有，
想过这件事情，
后来,
当我长大了之后，
当我上大学了之后，
我爸还要，
把他的诗作，
长篇大论的，
发给我的时候，
因为我不在他身边，
我不需要，
一直扮演那个，
称字的角色，
我就不会，
长篇大论的，
再评论很多了，
然后我就，
很能很明显的，
感觉我爸的失落，
然后,
我妈还会过来说，
你爸写的，
怎么怎么怎么样，
你也不评两句，
你也不夸他，
我妈还会作为，
我爸的进程，
来要求，
我这个，
已经被，
下放到，
远在宁古塔，
的一个，
折尘,
对我的行为，
进行一个要求，
我想到我的好朋友，
就是,
他是如何伤害他爸，
因为他爸是一个，
较为有名气的作家，
然后从小，
他也是跟你一样生活，
就是要拼读，
他爸爸的著作呀，
并且要说出这些，
然后他，
他从小就非常恨这件事，
可是他又没有办法反抗，
尤其是，
他现在已经长大了嘛，
然后他有一天，
他就跟我说，
他说我做了一件事情，
他说，我总有一天，
准备过几天，
就是告诉我爸，
就狠狠的伤害他，
他什么呢，
他爸开了一个抖音的账号，
他就给他爸买了一千个粉丝，
并且,
早上启动几个水军，
去表扬他爸发的那个，
因为他爸发抖音，
也是发他的诗文，
祝祝,
就表扬他很好，
然后他爸就很高兴的。
跟水军在交流，
他说我准备，
三天以后告诉我爸，
那是讲实话，
那是假的，
是我给你买的，
就是让他爸崩溃一次，
因为他爸，
非常骄傲的跟他说，
你看，我发了两天，
随随便便发了一些东西，
已经一千个粉丝了，
他就说，
我现在在家里点头，
他说，但是我要告诉他，
那一千，
都是我花钱给你买的，
就是,
根本没有人看你这些东西东西，
这就是他被他爸妈的报复，
我说，你爸会崩溃，
因为你想这样一个老头，
他就是，
已经觉得自己在，
你知道互联网上，
信了能够，
就是欣赏他，
文学水平的人，
你告诉他是姜师粉，
跟你讲话，
那些人甚至都不是真人账号，
你爸真的是，
就是会崩溃，
他说，对，
这就是我要的报复，
这就是我要报复，
他这么多年来，
你看他写的那些东西，
他说，当然，
他也不是非常没有水平，
他说,
但是根本不是我喜欢也读的那个东西，
真的,
而且我到现在都喊，
我被我爸写的诗，
你知道吗？
我觉得我作为一个小孩的记忆内存，
真的用了非常多，
在牢记我爸写的诗，
填了词上面，
你想想看你这个，
如果你真的是在国企面，
当一个，
你靠着这个，
赏西领导这个水平，
你都可以升好几级了，
可以了，
可惜，没有什么用，
对，不进入公龄啊，
好，我们刚刚讲完了，
驱动型父母，
下一个，
叫做消极型父母，
我觉得这个类型，
其实非常好别人，
叫做,
他们会避免处理，
任何让自己心烦的事情，
就是叫做，
不管,
他们明显比其他类型的父母，
危害要小一点，
但也有自己的负面印象，
因为他不管你嘛，
交小孩的那个权利，
他就会交给，
占据主导地位的办理，
因为,
家庭中，
两个家长，
可能一个是驱动型，
或者一个是情绪型，
他在小孩身上那个，
投入是非常非常大，
对小孩的控制，
是非常厉害的，
消极型父母呢，
他就在旁边看着，
他也不管，
甚至他们会对小孩，
受到的虐待和忽视，
视而不见，
他们对待问题的态度，
就是大事化小，
小事化了，
而且,
消极型父母，
他会有一个，
很强的迷惑型，
因为他们甚至，
可能会表现出来，
非常地和爱可亲，
很幽默，
他平时就会让小孩，
觉得说，
我的爸爸，
或者我的妈妈，
他才是那个，
好玩的，
幽默那个人，
而且是好人，
因为他，
比方说小孩，
对他提出一些要求，
比方说我要看动画片，
或者是我要玩iPad，
那对于这种家长，
通常就是为了麻烦，
就会说，
好好好，那你看一会儿好了，
然后小孩，
通常就会觉得，
这才是我的好爸爸，
或者这才是我的好妈妈，
对,
而且,
在消极型父母，
之下成长起来的小孩，
会怎么样呢？
因为他经历了几次，
这个家长，
他并不会在自己遭受到，
虐待啊，
或者遭受到忽视的时候，
真正关键时刻，
他是不会出来帮自己的，
所以他们会对这一位家长，
会对这一个父母，
他会有一个判断，
就会心里很清楚地知道，
不要希望，
从他那里得到帮助，
虽然,
消极型父母很喜欢，
跟小孩一起玩，
让小孩觉得自己很特别，
但是,
小孩其实时间长了之后，
就会知道，
他们并不会真的管你嘛，
而且,
这些父母，
对加害小孩的行为视而不见，
甚至,
还可能离开他们的孩子，
让孩子自己管自己，
如果,
母亲是消极型的，
那么他可能会和一个贬低，
或者虐待孩子的男人结婚，
因为他没有独立的收入，
这样的母亲，
对周围发生的事情很麻木，
比如,
一位母亲在提到她的丈夫，
对孩子施暴的时候，
有些轻描淡写，
她会说，
孩子爸爸有失也有难处。
因为我看到这一段的时候，
我特别看了一下，
评论,
然后评论里面，
有一个读者，
他就说，
妈妈经常说，
你爸就那样，
意思就是，
我不要和爸爸计较，
让一个孩子，
不要和父母计较，
让孩子包容父母，
现在想想，
这是多么可笑的话，
因为我，
肯定很多小孩，
也听过这种话嘛，
就你爸就是这样，
对吧,
他喝多了，
就是会打人。
而且,
还有一个负面影响，
叫做,
因为小孩在这样的情况下，
成长起来，
有两种可能，
第一种可能叫做，
你发现这样的父母，
不是真心对你好吗？
他会在关键时刻，
抛弃你，
你就知道这样的是错的。
那还有种情况，
叫做,
因为这样的父母，
表现的，
对跟小孩关系很好，
他们会产生一种，
那他是爱我的，
那这样是对的，
喜欢小姐行父母的孩子，
成年以后，
就会有可能，
为别人的抛弃行为，
找借口，
因为他们作为小孩，
他们就会认为说，
我爸爸妈妈，
为什么在我遇到困难的时候，
不管我是，
因为他们真的无能为力，
他们才会不管我的，
好,
这样的心态，
当他遇到了别人，
不公平地对待他，
伤害他的时候，
他也会觉得说，
那他也是真的没有办法，
而且好父母有责任，
在孩子们没能力保护自己的时候，
守护在他们身边，
这句话，
朋友们，
是不是听起来，
你小的时候，
不一定有人跟你说过吧，
反正我小的时候，
没有人这么跟我说过这句话，
而且你还会，
经常被你的其他的亲戚说，
爸爸妈妈不容易，
爸爸妈妈也没有办法，
就是你会加深，
你那个爸妈这么做，
是合理的这种概念，
对,
像刚刚那么简单的一句话，
但是对于这些孩子来说，
却对这种在正常不过的看法，
感到非常吃惊，
因为没有人这么跟他们讲过，
而且他们生活中，
也从来没有出现过这样的事实，
这些孩子从来没有想过，
父母有责任，
把孩子的幸福放在一个至少，
和父母自身利益，
同样重要的位置上，
然后我看到这个时候，
我就想，
我确实从来没有这么想过，
我就会觉得说，
我清楚的知道的一个事实是，
我爸爸妈妈，
我的父母，
他们最看重的是服从，
而不是我的幸福，
他们看重的是我的服从，
从小到大都是这样子的，
如果我不幸福，
那是因为我不够服从，
在逻辑还蛮通的，
对,
我对这个问题的看法，
是非常割裂的，
比方说我对于我自己，
比方说我现在是小猫的妈妈，
以后可能会成为
其他小孩的妈妈，
这件事情上，
我会要求我自己做到，
无论如何，
就比方说，
你要保护好自己的小孩，
因为他是小孩，
他没有能力保护自己，
在他没有成年之前，
你作为他的妈妈，
你肯定要尽你自己，
最大最大的努力来保护小孩，
但是,
当我爸妈没有做到这一点的时候，
我确实就像这些小孩一样，
会想说，
由于他们的时代局限性，
他们的受教育程度，
他们的成长环境，
他们确实做不到这一点，
我又会原谅他们，
理解他们，
会觉得说，
OK，他们也没有，
我们小时候没有人。
跟我们说过这个话，
他们小时候也没有人。
跟他们说过这种话，
他们也是在
这种环境里长大了，
这种代际传递，
他们并不是
第一代创造这种痛苦的人，
我又会这样子
来为他们开拓。
好，说到这里，
我要跟你举一个我妈，
我爸跟我的例子，
叫做我小的时候，
看了一篇格林文，
之类的，
就是有格言，
格林那种，
那里面一句金句，
叫做父母，
也是第一次做父母。
好，这句话，
对于小小的我来说，
产生了一个巨大的震撼，
就有一种，
哦，这样哦，
原来是这样。
对，原来是这样。
然后,
我回家之后，
做了一件事情，
叫做我跟我妈分享了，
我读到了这个东西，
哇，我妈如祸之宝啊。
在之后，
当我爸妈，
打我妈，
我伤害我的时候，
我爸妈，
就会把这句话拿出来用。
然后我当时就有一种，
我太傻了，
而且直到现在，
我爸妈还会
把这句话拿出来用，
叫做,
我们是第一次做父母，
所以就会有
做得不对的地方。
然后我想，
是的呀，
你们是第一次做父母，
难道我是第二次做小孩吗？
在亲子的关系里面，
孩子是绝对的弱势啊，
难道我能虐待你们吗？
就是,
如果你拿这个东西。
跟小孩本人去做沟通，
并且为自己的虐待行为，
找到一个合理原因的话，
我认为这是非常的卑鄙的。
就这个话，
可以由小孩
去理解父母的时候去想，
但是绝对不能，
被父母反过来，
拿过来说，
作为一个我行为的一个理由，
让小孩去接受，
我觉得这是非常不公平的。
所以这里面又存在一个，
虽然一句话看起来很有道理，
但是不同的人用，
就会产生截然不同的效果。
因为我前几天，
在小红书上，
还看到有一个妈妈，
新手妈妈，
就是在说这件事，
就是说她对她小孩，
多么多么的好，
但是后面她就被人骂了，
因为她就想说，
你看我为小孩牺牲的，
就是有多么大，
你不愿意读书，
那你以为我就愿意，
陪你去迪斯尼吗？
我也为你付出了很多，
然后大家就狂骂她说，
你怎么不请愿为小孩，
做这些事，
那你可以选择不要生她呀，
因为小孩没有要求你生她嘛，
对不对，
你既然决定要生小孩，
那你就注定了，
你要为小孩付出吗？
但我就觉得很多，
现在当代的年轻妈妈，
一方面，
当然我觉得很好的一点，
一方面是她，
有了一些自我的成长，
不会像老一代的妈妈，
就像我们的妈妈一样，
就是她的注意力，
或者她的人生都压在小孩身上，
一切以小孩为重，
万事就以小孩，
我的人生已经完蛋了，
那我希望你的人生能够过得更好，
就一切重心都放在小孩身上，
但同时，
这种无限膨胀的自我，
也会影响到她和她小孩的问题，
她就会想想说，
那我为什么要为你付出这么多，
我不是要先成为我自己吗？
难道我不是应该
以我自己的需求放在第一位吗？
我也觉得这个东西。
就是会有一些错位，
他们就会盲目的以这个观点，
为我的主要观点，
来忽视对小孩的照顾，
因为人在不同的环境里面，
他的位置，
他的相对位置是可能出现变化的，
当你在面对孩子的时候，
你就是绝对强势的，
而且你就是在小孩未成年期之前，
你就是要照顾他，
这个没有什么好说的，
但是在很多时候，
已经是会选择性的忽略的，
然后刚刚说到，
那个萧继心父母，
我有一个例子，
印象蛮深的是那个作者，
他讲的，
他说一个女生莫莉的故事，
他说莫莉的母亲是一个。
脾气暴躁，有虐待倾向的人，
他经常因为工作很累，
回家之后就会打骂小孩，
然后这个时候呢，
莫莉,
他是非常喜欢他爸爸的，
因为他爸爸是一个。
很温暖的，
性格很好的人，
但是呢，
他从来没有期望过父亲保护他，
因为,
比如说当母亲勃然大怒，
在书房里打莫莉的时候，
他就会听到他爸爸。
在厨房里面敲打锅碗，
就是那种大触拼拼棒棒的声音，
他觉得这是父亲声援他的方式，
他没有去想，
爸爸本来就应该介入，
并且停止，
不让妈妈打你对吧，
这是虐待小孩，
但是他就会觉得说，
我爸这样敲锅砸碗，
已经是在支援我了，
作者这时候就说了一句话，
叫做情感被剥夺的孩子，
不管怎样，
都试图乐观的看待自己，
喜欢那位父母的行为，
这就是一个经典的例子。
然后我就想，
我们这样去看的话，
小孩就是很可怜的，
因为他别无选择来你，
因为你想我们小时候，
是不是也听到过一个观点，
叫做,
哪怕我们是小孩的时候，
我们就听到人家教别人。
怎么做父母的观点，
叫做,
当一个人打小孩的时候，
另一个人即使不赞成，
也不要说出来，
以防被小孩看出来，
你们两个人是有意见分子，
是不是，
每个人都听过这种吧，
哪怕有一个人，
是不赞成打小孩的，
但是,
已经在打的这个过程中，
他是绝对不能站出来，
就是反驳另外一个人的，
因为这就会责损，
父母在小孩面前的微信，
以后,
小孩就再也不听，
爸爸妈妈的了，
因为想说，
你们两个人都意见不一致，
所以,
你看,
我们都没有当过父母的时候，
我们都听过这个，
从来没有人说，
打小孩就是不对的，
对于小孩，
绝对不能使用暴力，
没有的，
我们通常听到的，
教育叫做，
滚棒底下，
邱孝子，
对,
然后最后一种，
类型的父母，
叫做,
拒绝型父母，
我觉得，
他的作者介绍，
他的第一句话，
就很好笑，
他说,
拒绝型父母的所作所为，
会让你想知道，
为什么他们最初，
能够建立一个家庭，
什么叫做拒绝型呢？
就是,
无论他们的行为，
是温和还是严厉，
他们是不喜欢，
情感亲密的，
而且也不想被小孩打扰，
他们对别人，
需求的容忍度，
几乎是零，
他们跟小孩互动的时候，
就是命令，
或者发怒，
或者他就走了，
不参与到家庭生活里面了，
他说,
这一类人中，
一些比较温和的，
可能会加入到一些，
千篇一律的家庭活动中，
就是他不太，
需要付出太多心力，
但是他们仍然很少，
与人亲密，
或者真正的参与进去。
我觉得举个很典型的例子，
大家一定在，
某些场景里面，
看到一个小孩，
奔向他的父母，
可能是爸爸，
可能是妈妈，
然后那个家长，
就会抬头看一眼说，
去，找你妈去，
或者去，找你爸去，
这就是拒绝性父母，
因为他们，
第一个我觉得他们也是，
逃避育儿，
第二个也是，
他们没有办法建立，
就是小孩奔向你的那种亲密，
因为我姐夫就是这样一个家长，
他从小对于我外申女，
要去找爸爸玩，
一向都是说，
爸爸很忙，
找你妈去，
让你妈给你看看电视，
让你妈带你出去玩，
他就是这样一个家长，
以至于我至今，
他就很震惊，
我姐为什么要跟他结婚？
而且,
他是非常非常典型的，
不成熟的父母，
虽然跟这个拒绝性关系不大，
他到现在为止，
因为他不满意，
他在家里吃到的所有饭菜，
所以他就几乎不吃，
他不是说我要叫外卖，
或者是说，
我要自己做没有，
叫外卖，
他为什么不叫外卖呢？
很简单的原因，
就是真正能够让他。
达到满意的外卖很贵，
他也吃不起，
所以他既吃不起好的菜，
也看不起，
做的一般的菜，
于是他就不吃饭，
他就现在把自己瘦的，
他是一个一米八五的男的，
大概也就是一百一十斤左右，
把他瘦的跟个棍一样的，
然后我们全家，
就包括我姐，
还有他的女儿，
就我外甥女，
为了要哄他吃饭，
要千方百计，
从网上找到一个菜谱，
摸索到他的口味，
为了哄他，
让他多吃两口，
我就非常震惊，
我说,
为什么有人在做这个事呢？
他不吃就让他饿死呗，
他总有办法，
就是吃东西的呀，
比方说他饿个八顿，
然后他自己花钱，
吃一顿好的，
你就让他这样生活呗，
他有什么权利，
逼得全家围在他转啊，
但是你知道，
身为一个人的妻子，
和一个人的女儿，
你总是希望你在意的人，
就是能够吃到他满意的，
希望他开心，
在这种观念的驱使下，
我姐和我外甥女，
每天都要想办法，
摸透爸爸，
或者是老公，
今天想吃什么，
要不然就是，
今天我下班回来，
给他带一份，
什么茶餐厅，
什么好吃的东西，
要不然就是我外甥女，
她虽然是一个，
客业繁重的留着，
但她,
现在放春假回来，
每天在家里，
给爸爸做饭，
能想到这种事情吗？
我就讲，
那我外甥女，
跟我说这个事情，
我就觉得好震惊，
我就说，
为什么有人在做这种事啊？
为什么你们都，
就是在增香，
当他最贴心的女婆啊？
我有感觉到，
你们就是在，
就是在做这个事情啊，
然后我外甥女，
就是说，
哎呀,
我就是希望我爸，
不要受成那个样子，
小孩,
或者是老婆，
一旦产生了，
心疼男人，
就完蛋了。
我老实说，
心疼男人，
就完蛋了。
好,
说到你外甥女的行为，
我们接下来，
就可以进入一个，
非常重要的，
话题,
叫做,
在这种不成熟的父母的，
养育下，
小孩会分化成，
那两种主要的类型，
第一种，
叫做,
你外甥女这种类型，
是,
自我掌控者，
第二种类型，
叫做,
外物掌控者，
什么意思呢？
听着非常地学书，
其实,
很简单，
自我掌控者，
就会觉得说，
好,
这个事情，
我有办法。
所以,
他会努力地，
自己来做很多的事情，
无论是情感工作也好，
茶烟官色也好，
为父母做一些事情，
或者为伴侣，
为生活中的所有人，
做一些事情，
以及,
我要努力地加强我自己，
也许,
这个事情就会变好，
他的所有的东西，
为什么叫自我掌控者呢？
就是,
全部都是，
往自己身上走的，
去寻求，
这个,
事情的解决方案，
然后,
什么叫做，
外物掌控者呢？
就是,
小孩在这个过程中，
已经逐渐地崩溃了，
绝望了，
就会认为说，
这件事情我没有办法，
所以,
他,
遇到生活中的困难也好，
或者,
在家庭生活中，
遇到困难也好，
他就会，
直接往外撒出去，
就会发疯，
对,
就会觉得，
啊，我什么都做不好，
你就让我死好了，
就会变成一个，
卸丝底里的小孩，
对,
作者就说，
你采用，
哪种方式，
与其说是一种选择，
不如说是，
有你的个性和体制决定的，
归根结底，
我们都是为了，
让自己能在这个环境中，
存活下去，
或者,
过得更好嘛，
那随着，
你不断的长大，
你会经历很多的事情，
你的自我掌控，
或者外物掌控的特点，
都可能，
加强,
这也是，
你的人生经历，
和你的天性决定的，
那理想的状态是什么呢？
就是,
这两种东西，
像内球，
他达到一个平衡，
自我掌控的人，
需要学会，
寻求他人的帮助，
外物掌控者，
要学着掌控自己，
然后他就讲，
自我掌控者的特点，
他说,
很,
通常,
精神很活跃，
很爱学习，
他们通过反思，
或者自己的错误里面，
吸取经验，
来,
从内部解决问题，
他们很敏感，
常常试图，
理解事情的起因和影响，
他们把生命，
当做,
提升自我的机会，
所以很乐意，
去锻炼自己的各种能力，
他们相信，
自己可以更加努力，
来让事情变得更好，
会本能地承担，
起独自解决问题的责任，
听起来很好对不对，
朋友们，
一听这个就感觉，
这是一个对我们，
社会有用的人，
但是如果，
你在这样的家庭环境里面，
你走向了一个，
非常彻底的，
自我掌控者的方向，
有可能会导致什么呢，
就是你，
没有办法，
向外界求救，
然后你觉得，
所有的事情，
都是你自己的责任，
并且,
你会很容易焦虑，
你会很容易，
可能,
承担不住，
会出问题，
那这一类，
自我掌控者，
焦虑的主要来源，
是当他们，
冒犯了别人，
害怕被人说成，
骗子时，
产生的负罪感，
他们与人关系，
恶化的原因，
是因为他们，
过于自我牺牲，
然后,
又因为自己，
替别人，
做了那么多，
怨恨不一，
我觉得，
还有一种，
就是自我掌控者，
不仅仅是，
因为这个产生焦虑，
还有一种，
就是为了，
让别人高兴，
或者是，
而你在那种，
气氛之下，
你做出了一些，
你根本，
完成不了的许诺，
比方说，好，
我一定下次考试，
考第一，
那你根本，
考不到啊，
你已经很努力了，
但是,
考第一这种事情，
你不一定是，
很努力，
就能做到的嘛，
所以,
很多时候，
在这种情况，
你一方面，
你只会恨自己，
我为什么，
没有更努力一点，
你的父母，
或者是，
你的伴侣也好，
他不一定会，
你说,
他反而会说，
哟，不是要考第一的嘛，
做不到就别拿出来吹牛了吧，
那在这种的，
压力下，你，
自我掌控者，
走回更加的痛苦，
我就会想说，
你看,
我不仅是个能力不行的人，
我还是个说到，
做不到的人，
那我就是个骗子，
他就,
不停的会，
压榨自己，
嗯,
然后,
外务掌控者呢，
因为他在，
成长过程中，
有点像，
习的性无助一样，
所以他更多都会觉得说，
我现在这个情况，
靠我自己，
没有办法改变，
要这个世界来适应我，
所以会表现出来，
导致这一类孩子，
他们的仪人性，
非常低，
就是,
什么意思？
周围的人，
可能会不喜欢他们，
因为他们，
一遇到问题，
就推到别人身上去嘛，
也不会说，
我自己能为这件事情，
做什么，
会导致，
可能进一步，
比方说，
要是外务掌控者，
这个倾向，
特别特别强的话，
他可能也会进一步，
成为和不成熟的，
父母一样，
类型的人，
他们结婚生小孩，
可能也变成这样的父母，
就会形成一个恶性循环，
然后我看到，
一句话的时候，
我觉得很有意思，
是作者在写那个书的时候，
他说,
看到了这个章节，
你是很有可能，
是自我掌控者的，
因为自我掌控者，
很想知道原因，
很想知道有什么办法，
所以他们会来看这种书，
然后呢，
我看到那时候，
我也笑了一下，
我就觉得，
很有道理，
逻辑上来说，
非常说得通，对吧，
因为,
这明显是一个，
想要改变的人，
才会做的事情嘛，
他说,
自我掌控者的特点，
自我掌控者，
非常渴求，
与人的情感联系，
他们对人的亲密，
的质量非常敏感，
所以,
如果和情感不成熟的，
恐惧情感的父母，
一起生活，
他们从小到大的，
感觉就是两个字，
孤独,
因为爸爸妈妈，
不理解他们，
也不想理解他们嘛，
那这样的孩子，
就是觉得说，
我是,
没有人帮我的，
我只能靠我自己，
他的整个情感机制，
都是这样的话，
而且,
他找意思的是，
当这些孩子，
产生了孤独的，
这样的念头以后，
他反而又，
又会变成一个，
新的来责怪自己了，
他会觉得，
你看啊，
我爸妈，
也不是不给我付学费，
我生活的也挺好的，
我为什么，
还敢到孤独呢，
那说明我这个人，
不知满足，
不懂感恩，
又反而又一种，
来责怪自己，
但其实，
在这样家庭，
你长大的小孩，
孤独是一个，
非常非常，
正常的一个感受，
你有这样，
那个林赛博士拿出来，
就是衡量的标准，
你是否有一种，
我们家庭环境也不错，
条件也蛮好的，
爸妈也不是，
不给我花钱，
然后也不是完全的，
也不会家暴，
也不会打我，
那我,
为什么还敢到孤独呢，
如果你有这种感觉的话，
那你就有可能，
生活在一个，
你父母都很不成熟的家庭里，
他其实是一个，
判断标准，
而不是大家，
一产生这样的观念，
先第一个念头，
反省自己。
嗯,
不过我们现在，
说的很多东西，
因为,
不是他的这个书有很，
我觉得有很操作性的一面，
是他在每一个章节的背后，
他都有一些自策的题目，
会问你，
就不是说，
我给你提出一个概念，
你就自己去套吧，
你是还是不是，
那他会有很多的，
一条,
很多的表现，
来列出来，
还有包括说，
你的自我评价是什么样的，
你理想的自我，
是什么样的，
你为了，
维持住，
好像这个生活，
能够运转下去，
你逼自己，
成为了一个什么样的角色，
你认识的自我，
和角色之间的区别是什么，
他就有一些不同的问题，
来帮助你，
认识到你自己，
这个中间的差距有多大，
我觉得这个部分，
其实这本书，
很好的一个地方，
因为他不是纯将理论，
还是在帮助你，
认识自己的，
我觉得他，
讲了一个，
东西啊，
说自我掌控者，
非常渴求与人的情感联系，
因为我们现在在网上，
也会有一种，
声音就会觉得说，
你为什么，
要把你自己的感情，
寄托在别人身上呢，
这不是活该吗，
那你为什么不能，
独立一点呢，
你就当你自己的大女主吗，
你自己一个人，
难道不能活得很好吗，
你就非要，
到别人身上去寄声，
当然,
我们提倡大家要独立，
这件事情是很好的，
但是独立不是孤立，
我觉得这里面，
其实是有分别的，
林塞伯是这一段，
我觉得他讲的，
非常好，
他说,
为什么情感联系，
对人类来说很重要，
他说,
因为这个东西，
其实是有神经学家的，
研究能够证明这一点的，
他说,
有一个神经学家，
史蒂芬·波吉斯的研究，
就2011年的一个研究，
他说,
不如动物通过进化，
具备了一种独特的应对本能，
这种本能使得，
他们在接近，
或者接触别人的时候，
可以震惊下来，
而不是，
只像爬行动物一样，
遇到危险那什么的，
只有无意识的应急反应，
不如动物进化出来的这个东西，
能够通过和同类的接触，
让心率降下来，
并且降低，
因为压力带来的体力损耗，
什么叫因为压力带来的体力损耗，
朋友们上班，
你坐在那里坐了一天，
你什么都没有坐，
但你也很累，
为什么？
因为你有压力，
你的身体不由自主，
就很紧繃，
还是有损耗的，
这就是我们不如动物的，
进化出来的东西，
决定说，
我们体内有一些，
迷走神经通路，
已经进化到，
可以通过身体上的亲近，
抚摸,
舒缓的声音，
甚至眼神接触，
都可以来，
使你的应急的急速，
和心率降低，
这些震惊效果，
可以节约宝贵的经历，
也可以创造愉快的社会关系，
这种关系，
又可以促进群体的发展，
那对于所有的，
不如动物，
包括人类，
我们想要，
寻求安慰的时候，
危险可能不会消失，
但是,
我们只要，
跟我们，
所爱的同类，
待在一起，
就可以保持震惊，
这件事情，
为什么对我们很重要，
因为所有人，
都不是很轻松的活着的，
所有人的生活，
所以,
情感联系，
是我们进化出来的，
巨大优势，
是一种，
高效的应对，
压力的方式，
而不是说，
只能靠，
五意识的应急反应，
所以,
我们人去追求，
情感关系，
这是一个，
非常正常，
也合理，
也科学的需求，
没错,
然后我还注意到一点，
就是他讲了一个，
自我掌控者，
有可能会遇到的，
一种问题，
除了我们，
刚刚说的，
可能会过度责备，
什么什么，
在情感关系里面，
他们往往，
会走向一个，
不平衡的关系，
什么意思，
就是说，
一个,
向内求，
希望我自己，
能通过我自己，
改变,
让这个世界，
变得更好的人，
他们很有可能走向了，
服务别人，
他们去找了一个，
外务掌控者，
当自己的伴侣，
而,
他们做了很多的，
情感工作，
然后他们，
给予那个伴侣，
温暖,
满足他们的需求，
因为关系，
刚开始的时候，
那个外务掌控者，
找了他们的人，
会让你觉得，
哇,
你真的很特别，
你对我真的好好，
你让我觉得很温暖，
怎么怎么怎么，
但是,
一旦这个关系，
稳定下来了之后，
他就会变成一个，
只向你所去的人，
然后这时候，
这个自我掌控者，
就是我们现在，
一切都是，
想要自己解决的人，
就非常的恶然，
就会觉得说，
啊,
怎么会变成这样子，
他还举了一个例子，
我觉得很有意思，
是一个女神，
福基尼亚，
她说,
她受到了，
她哥的，
批评,
因为她哥是特别喜欢，
抓着她，
特别喜欢批评她，
而且她个性，
非常的专横，
这件事情，
对她的精神，
影响到了一个什么程度呢？
就是,
她,
从恐慌症，
就惊恐症中，
醒过来，
然后她为了，
解决自己的这样的一个，
过分在意，
她哥看法，
对她的生活，
已经产生巨大影响，
的情况下，
她就去，
就做心理治疗，
然后她发现，
她哥跟她，
已经死去的爸爸，
有个共同特点，
叫做,
非常喜欢否定她，
就,
你什么都做不好啊，
你这个，
你怎么会这么想呢？
怎么怎么，
总是会，
直高零下的指责她，
总是会让这个女生，
觉得说，
她很无能，
不值得被别人爱，
然后她就，
意识到说，
那我现在，
面对我哥的时候，
我会焦虑到，
晚上睡不着，
就会突然醒过来，
是因为，
她其实在重演，
她同年的那个情况，
那时候，
她总是试图得到，
她那挑剔，
而又亲灭的，
父亲的爱，
能如愿，
她潜意识的一个，
治愈性情境，
这个也是自我掌控者，
一个很常见的诉求，
就是我们希望有一天，
因为你足够好，
你做的足够对，
你就会，
终究得到那个，
你被治愈了的情况，
所以她的那个，
治愈性的幻想呢，
就是总有一天，
她会足够的证确，
从而得到，
父亲的认可，
然后这时候，
她爸爸已经死了，
所以她歌成了，
她爸的替身，
因为她是去找，
做这个心理治疗嘛，
她说,
如果有人对我，
表达了任何不快，
尤其是男人，
我会吓得不由自主，
认为一定是我做错了，
但是现在，
她能够，
把自己和哥哥的关系，
看得更透彻，
她是这么说的，
她说,
我一直把她，
当做是可以崇拜的偶像，
就像对待上帝一样，
她不在乎我，
但我会让她，
决定我的感受，
我一直很在意她的意见，
但现在，
我越来越独立了，
我觉得自己，
正在学习，
成为一个独立的人，
然后我就想到，
天哪,
我自己，
行了一个精神分析，
是一样的，
因为我差不多十年前，
不止十年前，
十几年前吧，
反正我当时，
跟一个男的交往，
他特别吸引我，
但是我不知道，
为什么，
因为他是那种，
非常不耐死的人，
就他很聪明，
也很刻薄，
我一开始觉得，
他吸引我的，
是这种聪明，
而刻薄的东西，
后来,
当我在长大，
可能又过了两年之后，
我反思我那一段时间，
那种非常不合理的，
因为我非常清楚地，
知道我不喜欢这个人，
但是我非常迷恋他，
就我不喜欢他，
但是我却非常在意，
他对我的看法，
我就想说，
为什么，
我就突然有一天，
我意识到，
他对我挑剔，
和不肯定我，
总让我觉得，
我需要得到他的认可，
这一点很像我爸，
我就那一天，
我突然意识到，
我好像在他身上，
寻求一种，
在我爸身上，
不可能得到的认可，
因为他在这一点上，
跟我爸很像，
所以我一旦，
能够得到他的认可，
我也 kind of,。
在我爸身上，
得到了我爸的认可，
然后我那一瞬间，
明白了，
天呐,
我在吃我爸的败餐，
这件事情好恶心啊！
但是林蔡博士讲了说，
自我长空的，
很容易陷入到，
这种情境里，
因为由于他们小时候，
在家庭里面，
跟不成熟的父母，
待在一起，
受到了一些情感虐待，
然后大家就知道，
最熟悉的模式，
就是最安全的模式，
当你又陷入到，
这种模式里，
你会不由自主地觉得，
哇，好熟悉啊，好安全，
就是这样长大的，
在这种关系里面，
我感到了，
就是如鱼得水，
也不叫如鱼得水，
我不用再去摸索，
或者创造一种新的，
相处模式，
我就这样相处，
我就会像原来一样，
我只要让大家都高兴了，
那这个万一，
就可以继续发展下去，
对你来说，
它是很顺理成章的一件事情，
但是林蔡博士，
还有一点，
就是说，让大家，
尤其是，
自我长空的，
就是你一定要记住的，
就是,
你无法改变，
不求改变的人，
当你跟一个，
在一起，
你做出了那么多的努力，
比方说，
你又懂事，
又体贴，
又善良，
又善解人意，
又把他的一切需求，
放在你的前面，
你无做了一切的事情，
让他感到舒适，
可是他仍然，
第一，他仍然有可能，
是不高兴的，
第二,
他仍然可能觉得，
你做的还不够多，
你做的还不够好，
因为一个人，
要挑另外一个人的次，
他实在太简单，
太容易了，
任何事情，
他都可以，
是不高兴的，
所以书里面，
就是说，
请记住，
这些愈合行幻想，
什么叫愈合行幻想，
就是我们刚刚说的，
你指望通过，
你自己个人的努力，
我要做的更好一点，
我要做的再懂事一点，
能让这个关系，
改善的想法，
作为孩子的自我掌控者，
往往会扮演救护者的角色，
他们觉得自己有责任，
去帮助别人，
甚至到了，
忽视自身感受的地步，
他们的治愈行幻想，
重视于，
这样一种想法有关，
叫做这个问题，
得由我来解决，
他们不知道的是，
自己已经承担了一项，
他人都从未做过的工作，
叫改变那些不求改变的人，
我觉得就是，
如果你已经意识到了，
自己是一个自我掌控者，
你就要注意这些话，
就是你要相信，
关系不可能是，
靠你一个人来改善的，
关系想要改善，
或者是说，
要变得更好，
有继续发展的可能性，
一定是双方共同努力，
只靠你一个人，
我们说的一个人努力，
一个人，
倒贴,
不能叫倒贴，
差不多是倒贴吧，
就是剃头单子，
不能一头热，
你一个人努力，
这个关系，
只会越来越倾斜，
它不可能达到，
你想要的平衡的，
而且我很喜欢，
他给出了一个，
很有操作性的建议，
叫做先了解你自己的感受，
他说,
根据我个人的经验，
人最不愿意承认的感情，
有两种，
一是害怕某人，
二是不喜欢某人，
他后面还举了很多，
他咨询的例子，
其实在很多情感上，
遭到虐待的小孩，
他们成年以后，
长大以后，
来寻求帮助的时候，
他们是不愿意承认，
自己其实害怕自己的父母，
或者是不喜欢自己的父母的，
他们到最后还是归结为，
我要是这样的话，
是不是太没良心了呢？
所以他们不能承认这件事情，
然后所以他讲到的第一点，
就是要先感受你自己心里，
真正是怎么想的，
就不要讲那些非常复杂的东西，
你要想像你是一个小学生，
你只会说非常非常简单的话，
他说我建议你在一个。
私人的地方做这件事情，
这样你就不用担心别人的反应，
然后大声或小声说出你的真实想法，
你可能会用
我不喜欢别人什么什么什么，
这样的句子来描述他们的行为，
当你触及自己的真实的感受的时候，
你会感觉身体上有一种解脱感，
不要让内就影响你的想法，
你只需要对自己说这些话，
只为发现自我，
没有人能听到你说的话，
大可放心，
而且他在这件事情之后，
他还讲了一个非常重要的点，
叫做有些人认为要实问题得到解决，
应该和另一个人正面对峙，
但我认为这样往往会适得其反，
我看到这个时候，
我有一种天哪没想到，
原来这不是唯一的办法，
他说,
因为如果你刚刚才开始了解你自己是怎么想的，
你急于跟人家去得出一个解决方案，
要彻底的改变这个事情，
可能会让你非常的焦虑，
因为这件事情就压力很大嘛，
而且更别说，
对方可能接受的并不好，
他根本就不愿意听你说，
你爸爸反过来，
劈头盖你，
把你臭骂一顿，
甚至打你，
或者说，
把你赶住家门，
或者怎么样，
就闹出了一个非常大的闹剧，
那在这种情况下，
可能会引起你进一步的崩溃，
如果愿意的话，
你之后可以随时跟这个人说话，
但在这之前，
最重要的是先理解你自己的感受，
要清楚一点，
告诉另一个人，
你怎么想的，
并不能帮到你，
了解自己，
了解自己的真实感受，
才能帮到你自己，
简单的承认真实的感受，
并把他们大声说出来，
就可以使你的情绪，
得到极大的平复，
我觉得这个还是我自己之前，
我没有太想过的一个问题，
因为我就觉得，
可能是我们这一类人，
就会很想，
太急于想解决一个问题，
就找到了一条路之后，
就说，好，让我们试一试吧，
让我们去沟通，
让我们去看看，
是不是能把这个事情说开了，
就好了，
或者怎么怎么样，
然后就受错，
受错了之后，
就不知道怎么办，
对，我就是想说，
我们总是，
老是怀着极大的内疚，
你知道甚至，
我跟我的好朋友，
说完别人的坏话以后，
我们俩都会补充两句说，
天呐,
我们俩天天说别人坏话，
我们是不是太贱了，
都会忍不住，
要再骂完别人以后，
还要再骂一番自己，
因为我们就觉得，
好像你要表示不喜欢哪个人，
就像刚刚临财博士这样的说的，
你总觉得，
你这就是一个很不好的行为，
你不喜欢别人，
但我看到评论说，
有一个朋友，
他就说，
如果你做这样的小测试，
你比较说，
也会有点压力的话，
你不妨可以开始写一些日记，
其实写日记也是一个很好的，
自我的倾诉，
和自我的疗愈，
临财博士他还举了一个例子，
天呐,
我又觉得，
我看到了我自己，
他说的这个女生，
他是一个叫做莱娜的女生，
他的生活除了狂热的工作，
就是不断满足对别人的需要，
甚至对在院子里养的宠物，
他都照顾得无微不至，
如果一颗植物，
因为没有浇水而略显枯萎，
他会被赶内疚，
然后我想天呐，
我在家的大分时间，
都在给植物浇水，
你好啊，
你记下来，
你还会放流放去啊什么，
你已经承认自己对植物有区别对待，
并且可以坦然面对这件事情啊，
确实当我看到他枯萎，
或怎么样的时候，
我心里还是会非常不舒服的，
但是他的重点是在于说，
这个女生她抱了一个健身班，
来帮自己减压，
朋友们注意她的目的是减压，
然后,
但是呢，
她刚抱板，
她就想要跟上节奏，
做到完美，
所以把自己累坏了，
然后她在上课的过程中，
哇，出现了一个非常经典的心态，
我们之前吃的苦中苦，
真的能成为人上人吗，
那一期的时候就讲过，
我们有很多朋友都会有类似的心态，
叫做坚持，努力，
不要放弃，
你上来就放弃了，
以后就成不了大事，
什么什么，
我们会特别想要
让自己成为一个能吃苦的人，
她说,
但是在莱娜的这个例子里面，
她说第二天早上醒来的时候，
她发现大脑和身体似乎有点不太挺使唤，
她试图在地上走几步，
但是腿很疼，
脚都几乎抬不起来了，
她才意识到，
昨天有点用力过猛，
莱娜长期忽视身体的疲劳，
她那苛求的母亲，
反而帮助她养成这样的习惯，
小时候，
如果她不把事情做得够快，
或者不够努力，
母亲就会骂她懒惰，
因此,
她从未按自己的节奏做过任何事情，
对于身体的极限，
也毫不在意，
然后我就想，
什么叫做按照自己的节奏做事情？
我看到这里的时候，
我真的陷入了沉思，
然后我就想，
可是像我这样的人，
如果我不强迫自己的话，
我就做不成任何事啊，
而且,
我们也常常听到一句话，
叫做你不逼自己，
怎么知道自己的极限在哪里呢？
对呀,
你知道我不是最近在看脚踝吗？
然后我就跟我的医生说，
我说,
等每次我散步，
散到八千步以上的时候，
我的脚就会痛，
然后医生说，
那你为什么要散到八千步？
我都被她问愣住了，
我想说，对呀，为什么？
然后我又习惯，
现在我回答我说，
不是常常说，
每天就是要散步啊，
差不多要走几公里啊，
然后医生说，
那也没有必要走到八千步吧？
我就说，
那我探索出来了，
这就是我脚痛的界限啊，
然后医生说，
不是这样的，
是你每痛一次，
她又发言了，
就是你每天都在让她发言，
但是医生没有反问我之前，
我确实没有意识到，
我为什么每天就是要走到八千步？
就好像，
而且我还觉得我走少了，
你知道吗？
因为我平常都走一万多步，
我走到八千步就痛的时候，
我就想说，
那我今天走八千差不多了，
我认为自己已经在偷懒了，
我也是，
我也怎么认为？
关于这一种心态，
我们的作者，
他是这样分析的，
他说,
莱娜渐渐开始详细，
因为他妈对她的言格，
要求非常非常严格，
他说,
所以他成长过程中，
就逐渐相信，
做一个好人，
意味着即使没有准备好，
或者生活有些失衡了，
也要不断驱使自己，
实现所有目标，
在追求母亲认可和爱的过程中，
莱娜已经形成了一种信念，
就是只有非常努力，
才能配得上一些东西，
莱娜同年的愈合型幻想，
有一天，
她那苛求的母亲，
在看到莱娜付出了巨大的努力，
来取决自己后，
会开始体谅和欣赏她，
而且,
就像我们刚刚说的，
不止妈妈会这样，
社会也会鼓励你要吃苦，对吧？
你要做事情都竭尽全力，
永不放弃，要做到最好，
然后作者就说，
但是对于一个像莱娜一样的人，
这样的信念如同心灵的堵腰，
就你可能就会把自己的身体搞坏，
或者你把自己的精神搞崩溃了，
因为本人就是既把我的膝盖，
把我脚踝，
和我的宽，
都是这样练坏了，
当然我也是很容易焦虑，
我就觉得在她身上，
我在看这些例子的时候，
我就有一种全球的爹妈，
只是程度有所区别，
因为在有些地方，
打小孩可能会被抓起来，
但是类型上，
和造成的问题上的方向性上，
都是会有很多重合的，
我在看莱娜的故事的时候，
我就觉得天呐，
就是跟我也挺像的，
对，而且你知道吗，
今天小红书的热搜，
还有一个叫做努力的，
然后我就点进去看了一下，
然后原来是讲说，
全都是人怎么能写出，
这么努力的金句，
里面的句子差不多都是说，
人只要付出什么，
短暂的努力，
就可以过上隐移，
一辈子都过不上的生活，
这难道还不划算吗？
还有说什么，
只苦就算一口，
一次性把苦吃掉，
而不是分阶段性的，
一点一点的苦吃，
所以你现在要做的，
大概就是捏着鼻子，
一口气把这个事给干了，
我想说，
这跟我们刚刚讲的是一样的，
我们的热搜还在鼓励这个东西，
并没有说，
什么大家什么要躺平了，
没有啊，
就还是有在什么卷啊，
鸡娃啊，
这个东西，
是一个社会文化的东西，
并不是说我们自己内心，
想说我要按我自己生活的节奏来，
你自己一个人心里的声音，
怎么可能抵得过你爸妈，
然后加上你身边的朋友，
以及整个社会
对你灌输这个东西，
这根本就是不可抗衡的，
然后说到社会灌输，
观念这件事情，
作者讲了一个点，
我觉得让我微笑了一下，
他说特定的社会文化，
也会使我们无法看清自己的父母，
为什么？
因为文化传统给我们灌输了一下观念，
叫做所有的父母都爱他们的孩子，
父母是你唯一能够相信的人，
父母永远支持你，
你可以把一切都告诉父母，
父母无论如何都会爱你，
你随时都可以回到家里去，
父母只会考虑什么是对你最好的，
父母比你自己更加了解你，
无论他们做什么，都是为你好，
然后他最后就加了很短的一句话，
他说,
但如果你的父母情感不成熟，
以上的很多情况都是不成立的。
好，希望大家能够再听我们这期节目，
以及看到这本书以后能够学会分辨，
哪一些是不成熟的父母，
以及你能挑出我们刚刚上书的那些句子里面，
有哪些是不成立的？
对，当然，已经讲了那么多问题，
作者就会提供一些解决方案，
他提供的解决方案叫做。
我们怎么应对这样的情况，
第一个叫做独立观察，
我觉得他讲的这个独立观察，
他首先提到了一个理论，
家庭系统理论，
他说是家庭治疗师，
莫瑞报文1978年提出来的，
他这个理论是描述情感不成熟的，
父母如何与他人陷入情感糾葛，
这种糾葛的产生，
往往是因为父母不尊重别人的边界，
把自己没有能解决的问题强加到孩子身上，
同时对孩子的生活大加干涉，
在被情感不成熟的父母控制的家庭当中，
家庭成员会扮演各自的角色陷入糾葛之中，
来使家庭成员保持亲密，
这个亲密打了个引号，
当然在这种家庭中，
其实没有真正的沟通和情感亲密，
没有人会因为展现真实的自我而得到认可，
此外在充满糾葛的家庭中，
如果和某人有矛盾，
你不会直接找此人和解，
而是向第三方谈论他，
报文称这种方式为三角战术，
他认为这种糾葛如同胶水一样，
把家庭成员静静的黏在一起，
然后就想，好是的，
所以当我因为我被我爸妈，
被刺之后，
他们会找所有的七大姑八大姨，
还有我的中学同学，
各种人当说客，
要求我跟他们恢复联系，
但是对于我怎么说的，
我对他们提出的一些要求，
基本上就完全不尊重，
但是他们会有很多间接的方式。
通过第三方来对我进行干涉，
好，这样第三方又强迫你们几个年在一起，
对，你忘了你小时候，
你爸妈要离婚，
就是把你也拉出来作为第三方，
像你亲素啊，
我在评论里面看到有一个人，
他的非常让我震惊，
他说他跟他老婆刚结婚那段时间，
每次和他老婆矛盾，
无法跟他沟通，
他就是跟他的丈母娘亲素，
让他的丈母娘来好好管管他的小孩，
那就是我没有想到我会看到这样一个评论，
因为我们通常以为的都是，
比方说爸妈，
就是像你刚刚说的，
他存在于一个家庭里面，
或者是大家庭里面，
我没有想到结了婚了，
还会有一种把丈母娘拉进来的这个，
What's that?。
那你要这么说的话，
当我爸妈跟我跟我的前夫。
当时有矛盾的时候，
他们选择的方式也是告假章，
就是去找我前夫的父母，
去说我们不好，
我的天呐，
你们已经不是三角关系，
你们已经是八角关系了。
但是他们借助的这个方式也是非常典型，
就是第三方吗？
实际上我前夫的父母对此事的评论，
就说不知道他们怎么像的，
跟我们来说我们儿子不好。
我作为女儿，
我听到这样的话的时候，
我内心也是非常的苦涩，
我就觉得说，
嗯，怎么像的呢？
我也不知道。
然后作者提出，
你要在面对这样的情况的时候，
你可以尝试的叫做保持观察者视角，
就是你要观察他们实际上在干嘛，
因为有很多时候，
你会被他们的情绪传染，
然后你会觉得很痛苦，
你也觉得你有义务对他们的这个，
种种的，
比如说，
那个妈就觉得说你对他不够阴晴，
你都没有注意到他要喝水，
你都没有问他要不要喝水，
对，类似这样的情况，
而且他在这里面有特别提到了，
就是如果你在观察父母的时候，
你又变得情绪化了，
或者是你发现变得敏感了，
就要默默提醒自己，
抛开情绪，
比方说最简单的就是，
如果比方说你跟你爸妈在一起，
你就很痛苦，
你就找个理由与人保持关系，
然后有很多朋友就说我没有办法搬出去，
那其实你不要跟他待在同一个房间里，
哪怕你是去上个厕所，
或者是跟你的猫，
或者跟你的狗玩一玩，
或者你只是简单的在家附近小区里面散散步，
就是离开，
正式的物理性的离开他的视野，
其实就是一个很好的中断，
如果比方说你们不是平常住在一起的关系，
比方说你在电话上，
今天你爸和你妈又开始说一些，
让你又陷入痛苦的东西，
你就找个借口挂电话，
你就比方说我老板找我了，
或者是说有人来敲门了，
就是迅速的挂电电话，
不要在保持观察的时候，
又重新陷入了这种痛苦的情绪当中。
作者又提出了一个东西叫做关联和关系，
就是说你可以不跟你情感不成熟的父母，
建立关系，
而只是跟他们建立关联，
这两者是不一样的，
因为建立一段真正的关系，
你们要对彼此开放和对方保持情感互惠，
如果尝试与情感不成熟的人，
建立亲密关系，
你可能会感到沮丧无力，
如果你向他们寻求感情上的理解和支持，
你的内心可能会不平衡，
为什么呢？
因为所有的情感工作是你做的，
是你在观言查识的，
实际上是他们在这段关系中获得好处，
在这一类情况下，
你跟他们建立关联更合适，
然后把对亲密关系的期望留给那些。
能够真正给你亲感回馈的人，
然后在这个过程中，
还有一些成熟意识法，
叫做专注于结果而不是关系，
不要急于和对方建立亲密关系，
要善于控制，
你表达完了之后，
就不要把这个事情放在心上，
然后他都分别讲了，
什么叫做专注于结果而非关系，
这个打个很简单的比方，
就是你跟你妈说一件事，
或跟你爸说一件事情，
你只要关注在这件事情，
目的达成了吗？
比方说这件事很简单，
就是我今年过年不回家了，
好，你告诉他们，
并且跟他们说清楚了，
我就是今年过年不回家了，
这就是你要达到的目的，对吧，
你不要再陷入他说，
哎呀，过年啊，
爸爸妈妈难得跟你一家团圆啊，
这个时候你都不回家，
这就是他又要把你拉进关系里，
但是这个时候你就要focus在，
我要的结果是什么，
我要的结果就是不回家过年，
你只要清楚的记得，
我们要达到的目标，
而不要被他的这种情绪。
又拉进这种泥沼里，
对，以及，
他说,
如果你一定要跟他，
就谈一件事情的话，
掌控好你们交谈的时间和主题，
也许是更好的选择，
因为,
他也很有可能，
你在跟他聊的时候，
他要去掌握那个话题的走向，
聊着聊着聊着飞了，
你要讲的那个事情，
他就不回答你，
然后你要问的问题呢，
他就跟没听见一样，
在这种时候，
你可以多次提问，
直到你得到明确的回答，
因为情感不成熟的人，
一般耐不住别人的坚持，
然后他后面还有关于一些，
这种成熟意识法的，
这个常见的问题，
我觉得很有意思，
因为作者就预测了，
你会对他们提出一个什么样的问题，
比方说，
有人可能会觉得说，
如果在思想上和父母保持距离，
我会觉得很愧疚，
觉得自己不坦诚，
我想要和他们开放而自然的相处，
然后作者就说，
客观的观察，
并不意味着你不坦诚，
或者虚伪，
这仅仅意味着，
你想把自己，
从伤害每一个人的情感漩渦中，
拯救出来，
作为一个成年人，
你想要独立思考，
其中就包括中立的态度，
与他人交流，
有清晰的自我意识，
不代表，
你对别人不忠诚，
然后,
又会有人说，
我非常同意，
不要被父母情绪左右，
可是你不知道，
我爸妈真的很疯，
他们的情绪非常的激烈，
很善于操纵我，
我在他们激烈的反应面前，
我没有办法，
作者是这样回答的，
他说,
任何一个人的情绪，
都有可能把我们压倒，
这就是众所周知的情绪感染，
如果你有意识的，
有目的的观察一切，
你就会更有安全感，
这也能减轻你的压力，
他特别讲理点，
他说要意识到，
这是他们的痛苦，
不是你的痛苦，
如果他因为他的感受，
在对你大发作的时候，
你或许能够体会到，
其中的一些苦处，
但没有必要承担，
同样分量的一个痛苦，
没错,
这就是我们常常说的，
那种课题分离，
他的痛苦，
就应该由他去解决，
而不是由你去解决，
然后又会有人说，
我的父母对我非常好，
他们跟我上学，
并且借钱给我，
如果把他们看作，
情感不成熟的人，
我会觉得很不尊重他们，
我也觉得这么看待他们，
不大合适，
这个想法，
我大概十几年前也有过，
然后呢，
这个作者这样回答了，
他说想法没有对错之分，
只有行动，
才分对错，
你不是不尊重他们，
你只是认清了
父母情感的局限性，
要做一个
情感成熟的成年人，
你必须在心里不断的观察，
评估他人，
你可以为父母
给予你的一切，
去感激他们，
尊重他们，
但无需假装，
他们没有人心的弱点，
拥有自己的观点，
并不是对父母不忠诚。
对，他下面还提供了。
一个非常具体的方法，
叫做,
当父母让我感到内疚的时候，
我到底要怎么样保持。
冷静并且客观的观察呢？
林赛博士是这样说的，
叫专注于你的呼吸，
体会呼吸的过程，
感到内疚，
并不是什么紧急情况，
你要还是要观察
现在正在发生的一切，
并且用确切的词汇。
跟自己描述这一切，
在内心描述所发生的事情，
会让你更有逻辑，
更加客观，
当然，你也可以开始计时，
每次父母说话的时候，
你就可以开始看时钟说，
好，我决定，
比方说再听他们讲三分钟，
当你不想听下去的时候，
你就可以礼貌地打断他们说。
你要走了，
或者要挂电话了，
或者就是我们刚刚说的，
你可以找个任何的借口，
就是没有必要再
继续交谈下去了，
你也可以轻轻的跟自己说，
没有必要感到内疚，
他们只是想把自己的感受。
强加在我的身上，
我没有做错任何事情，
我有选择的权利，
你一定要提醒自己，
就是当你父母
试图分散你的注意力的时候，
你等于再和一个
心烦意乱的小孩相处，
就是把你的父母当成小孩，
只要你冷静，
并且把注意力放在。
你想要的结果上，
就是我们刚刚说的，
你只是想要不想回家过年，
这个不愉快，很快就会过去，
因为讲真的，
你只要坚持，
你不想回家过年，
你爸妈不可能真的。
来到你的城市，
把你绑架塞到车里，
把你拉回家，
这个事情是不可能发生的，
你只要坚持这个事情，
OK，你只要做成的这个事情，
其实我觉得，
你就在这个
和不成熟父母相处当中，
你就已经
进了很大一步，
因为你知道了自己要做什么了，
而且还有一个问答，
我的印象非常深，
很有意思，
作者列出的担心叫做。
我的父母总是不开心，
我非常担心他们，
我只想让他们好受写，
好，这也是
我常有的一个感觉，
然后作者是这样回答的，
他说你做不到的，
你有没有发现，
无论你做什么，
他们都不会开心太久，
他们并不是因为
想要开心而抱怨，
那只是你的理解，
你只需要有善地对待他们，
但不要因为他们而受伤，
他们的治愈型幻想和。
角色型自我，
让他们遭受了很多痛苦，
让他们抱怨迫身，
你没必要因为他们放弃。
你自己的生活，
或者试图从后面推他们一把，
来让他们改变嘛，
如果你这么做了，
他们可能会更加的不开心，
更难相处，
后面他还举到了一个例子，
有一个女生Rebecca，
来咨询的时候，
就是说她的妈妈，
是一个外务掌控者，
她总是抱怨，
就算女儿费劲心思，
讨她的欢心，
她还是不开心，
而且她有一天，
就是在跟作者聊天的时候，
她说,
我就是想要我妈开心起来，
这也没有什么不对的吧，
作者就说我大叫起来，
不是这样的，
因为这个女儿，
她在和母亲相处的时候，
一直扮演着自我牺牲的角色，
总是试图让妈妈开心起来，
对于女儿来说，
是一个很严重的问题，
我问Rebecca,。
有没有证据，
说明她的母亲，
确实很想开心起来呢？
我们当时看到这个时候，
我都笑了一下，
我觉得，
我从来没有思考过这个问题，
当然我觉得，
这个问题也不能说那么绝对，
因为当你用这个东西，
去指责被家暴的妇女，
为什么不离开她所处的环境的时候，
我又认为她是眼科的，
但是,
如果你是处于一个，
不是那么极端的环境里面，
你作为一个对于自己的生活，
应该负责的成年人的情况下的话，
那女儿确实不应该对母亲的情绪负权责，
不应该是女儿一直围着妈妈转，
想要满足这个妈妈，
想要的所有的东西，
后来,
因为作者跟Rebecca聊了这个事情吗？
她就说，
有一天晚上，
Rebecca花了一整天试图，
让妈妈开心起来，
却为果，
她非常挫摆，
正准备离开妈妈家的时候，
她妈妈看着她说，
以后常来看望我哦，
Rebecca大吃一惊，
是不是在她做了这么多努力之后，
母亲真的想要的，
也仅仅是让她常去看自己呢？
Rebecca就想,。
我试着相信一下她的话吧，
她控制自己对母亲的同情，
适当的给予帮助，
这样她就不会去害怕拜访母亲了，
最后她发现，
她妈妈永远也高兴不起来，
但这不是她俩的问题，
没错,
当她已经做到了她妈妈要求的，
经常去看她，
之后也不会自作主张的，
就是想要费尽心机，
想要让她妈妈高兴起来之后，
她妈妈还是不高兴，
就无论你是很努力也好，
还是不够努力，
也不是说不够努力吧，
就是只做她要求的事情也好，
她妈都不高兴，
因为我又觉得你要满足别人的愿望，
实在太难了，
比方说你妈要高兴起来，
或你爸高兴起来，
是你要成为美国总统，
他才高兴，那你怎么办呢？
或者是他要让你成为全国首富，
或者是更低点要求，
他要你嫁一个，
他满意的男人，
他才高兴，那你怎么办呢？
你能不能为了满足他，
你就把你自己的一生全部放弃，
或者是说你拼命努力，
你也知道你不可能。
达到这样的要求，
你怎么办呢？
我每次听到有这样的问题，
就是哎呀，我怎么样能让我妈。
更高兴一点，
或者是让他高兴一点，
他就不会来烦我了，
我都会给我的朋友一个建议，
就是你不可能做到的，
因为父母的要求是这样子的，
当你满足了一，
他就会有二，
满足了二，他就会有三，
他永远不可能说你做太好了，
我太高兴了，
我从此以后就满足了，
一定要记得，
农夫和金鱼的故事，
人的需求是无法满足的，
不管这个人是善良的人，
还是邪恶的人，
还是什么贪婪的人，
人就是贪婪的，
人的欲望是无法满足的，
如果你爸妈想要自己高兴的话，
那他自己就去做美国总统，
他自己就成为全国首富，
他自己就会嫁给张琳赫，
或者是宋威龙，
whatever,。
就是他自己去嫁一个。
他满意的人就好了，
这不是你也应该做的事情，
我觉得大家一定要想清楚这个问题。
然后作者还提出了一个，
我没有想到过，
他会提出来的一个角度，
他说,
要当心情感不成熟的父母，
突然地坦承。
他说,
这是一种什么情况呢？
就是,
叫做当孩子对父母的。
举动无动于衷的时候，
这类父母最后可能会走向，
最后一波，
就是叫做我跟你真诚的交流。
他说,
我建议，
如果在采用你的独立观察法。
和目标导向法的时候，
你的父母表现出异常的坦承，
你要谨慎一点。
因为这时候，
你可能会因为心软，
再次陷入过去的治愈性幻想中，
因为你会觉得，
啊，他开始在意我想什么了吗？
他开始在意我想要什么了吗？
他说，千万小心。
你内心的那个孩子，
一直希望，
父母终有一天会发生改变，
并满足你的需求，
但你真正需要的是，
保持独立的成年人身份，
与你的父母保持联系，
而不是回到过去。
因为,
你想要的是和他们建立，
成年人之间的关系，
而不是成年人和小孩子之间的关系。
因为他说，
这里面有个很大的问题是，
这一类父母，
他其实没有办法处理真正的亲密，
当你因为觉得说，
啊，他要跟我真正的亲密，
他要跟我敞开心扉了，
好，你去再跟他敞开心扉的时候，
他接不住你，
然后他就会转向什么呢？
控制你。
这件事情，
就又回去了，
你又回到了，
你想曾经想摆脱的那个节奏，
所以，他说，
最后你和父母的关系，
会按照一定的规律进行下去，
你对他们需求越多，
他们在情感上越不可靠，
你对他们需求越少，
他们就会变得越可靠，
所以,
你只有在保持一个客观观察的姿态的时候，
你才能对他们放心，
很不幸，
但这就是事实，
他们害怕面对你内心的孩子的情感需求。
没错。
当然我也希望，
真诚的沟通是可行的，
但另一方面我们，
我自己，
我不说我们吧，
我自己去进行理性思考的时候，
我就觉得，
我的父母都活了这么大岁数了，
他的人生经历让他变成了他这样的人，
社会没有改变他，
他们彼此之间没有改变他，
他们的父母也没有改变他吧，
然后我作为他的孩子，
在他概念中的下位者，
想要几句话去改变他，
这本来就是一个概率非常非常非常小，
确实不太可能的事情，
我觉得在最后的一些操作的事情上面来说，
作者给出的建议我总结，
一个观点叫做允许放弃，
你要学会放弃，
你在已经知道有些事情注定做不到的时候，
放弃幻想，
控制预期，
做你能做到的事情，
这就是我学到的最大的东西。
而且我最大的感受是，
我觉得跟我爸，
因为我爸已经去世了，
跟我妈沟通是不可行的，
因为他没有认为他需要改变，
我觉得这个是最大的沟通障碍，
你跟他说，
我觉得你哪里哪里做的不好，
他并不承认这一点，
我觉得人和人之间，
进行真诚的沟通，
或者是平等的沟通，
那我们需要有一个共识，
有一个基础，
就是我认为你哪里做的不好，
你觉得啊，
我好像这里是做的不好，
那我们就会讨论，
这个不好在哪里，
以及如何改正嘛，对吧，
如果你要跟你妈说，
或跟你爸说，
你觉得哪里哪里不好，
你爸会大发脾气，
或者你妈就开始控诉你，
不孝顺啊，
你现在就是吃饱饮了，
你现在长大了，
就开始找我的毛病了，
我心里哭一哭，
你又被拖回这样的一种，
讨论进地区，
你是无法进行沟通的，
所以我就觉得作者，
他在最后一张说的就是，
我们有拥有做人，
不完美的自由，
我们应该有拥有自己，
真是想法和感受的自由，
以及暂停跟你爸妈，
接触的自由。
当你没有办法做到，
我们刚刚说的，
你甚至连跟他接触，
或者是你每次跟他讲话，
根本做不到什么保持观察，
也做不到什么focus在呼吸，
甚至你跟他传递的，
表达完了止作中结果，
你都做不到的话，
我觉得最简单的就是，
像燕窝一直在做的就是，
把爸妈拉黑了，
短暂的拉黑，
让我们大家都冷静一下，
让我们大家都先处理好，
自己的情绪，
如果你自己现在，
本身就已经在情绪黑洞，
你的压力很大，
你就很痛苦，
你还要被，
你一跟你爸妈交流，
又会陷入，
让你更深的痛苦，
因为你可以预见到，
他会对你说什么话，
那必然不可能是，
就是让你疏心的话，
那你的精神的健康，
已经无法支持你，
再做一些努力了，
那么我们就是听作者的话，
我们就是暂停接触，
对，以及最后，
我想在节目的结尾，
是分享这个作者，
写的最后一张里面的内容，
我特别有感触，
他说,
他那个小杰的标题叫做。
对父母一无所求的自由，
他说,
因为情感不成说的父母，
普遍会让孩子，
把父母当作幸福，
和自尊的主要来源，
以自我为中心的父母，
很喜欢孩子对他们有所渴求，
这样他们就会成为孩子的中心，
然后从二进一步，
控制你的生活嘛，
但是退一步，
闷心自问，
你是否真的需要父母，
或者说，
他们是否，
希望你需要他们呢？
这个想法可能看上去很激进，
但是,
如果不是因为家庭角色和幻想，
你可能压根儿，
不会对他们有任何需求，
因此,
考虑你是否要他们，
这个问题是很实际的，
或者说，
这是否只是一种，
同年没有得到的满足的，
需求的延伸，
他们现在，
真的有，
你想要的东西吗？
与任何情感不成熟的人，
建立联系，
无论是配偶，
朋友或亲属，
都可能存在这种奇怪的现象，
即便对对方，
没有任何需求，
你还是很渴望，
和对方建立联系。
因为我觉得，
很多朋友，
尤其是生活在，
中国或东亚的朋友吧，
会有一种，
天哪,
我如果跟我爸妈都相处不好，
那我这个人该是多失败？
我们大家都会有一种这个概念，
但是你要，
仔细的想一下这个逻辑，
他这句话其实是没有逻辑的，
并不是说，
你跟你爸妈都相处不好，
你这个人就很糟糕，
你这个人很失败，
因为也有可能是他们很糟糕，
他们很失败，
你跟他处不来啊，
对吧,
但是大家通常会有一种，
我爸妈都不爱我，
那我这个人就完蛋了，
那没有人可能会爱我，
我跟我爸妈都处不来，
那我完蛋了，
任何人都处不来，
但是大家要相信这句话，
其实他是没有逻辑的。
没错。
好，那今天跟大家讨论这么多，
也非常欢迎大家去阅读这本书，
叫做《不成熟的父母》，
然后他在微信读书就有，
可是微信读书的话，
要开通会员才能够阅读，
如果大家有，
比方说，
也可以去买纸质书，
因为我认为这本书。
还比较值得收藏。
没错。
好，大家也可以看，
因为这本书，
就像刚才我讲的，
他的每一张的前头，
每一张的开头和接尾，
都会有一些自测。
就是你的父母，
到底是不是不成熟的父母，
或者他是哪一种类型，
以及你对于你的自我觉察，
或者你的自我需求，
有哪一些，
他都会给你列出，
很仔细的一条一条的，
小的条例，
你可以按照他来自我测评一下。
反正我们的最终结果就是，
虽然作者给了一些方法，
但我们相信，
肯定他在真正的实操起来，
对于很多朋友，
还是有巨大的困难的，
毕竟和自己的父母，
开始沟通或严肃对话，
他本身就是一件很难的。
因为我们跟父母之间的权利，
依然我可以说，
到现在为止，
他仍然是不平等的嘛。
对吧?
所以就，
大家看一下书，
至少能够了解自己，
能够了解你父母，
是否属于不成熟的父母，
你能确定于这一点，
我觉得你能少一点，
对于自我的焦虑，
少一点责怪自己，
少一点恨自己，
就已经是一个很好的事了。
没错。
好，那我们今天就到这里啰。
那我们下次见吧，拜拜。
拜拜。